puis j'ai fini c'était génial
[Musique]
tous les outils pour entretenir
facilement votre jardin gama batterie
par style uniquement chez les revendeurs
style à gré
[Musique]
partout
trois jeunes enfants
[Musique]
rechercher la mer et dans votre nature
vous la faire vivre et dans la nature de
costa réservez votre balcon sur la mer à
un prix exceptionnel
l'annulation est gratuite costa
mais magic elles sont vraiment magiques
pour lire magique au soleil magique non
et quand je fais master est ce encore
plus magique je sais c'est pas moi c'est
apple quelques secondes correction c'est
magique avec deux clips eau chaude ses
149 euros seulement dispositif médical
[Musique]
wyeth est honnête
m
nouvelle seat leon découvrez-les
hybrides rechargeables et sans
engagement
[Musique]
et nos meilleurs jeux descartes et
distribuer accroche toi on va jusqu'à la
river et
l'espé a fugué prends ta chance
quand deux cas de maux
elle en les recettes sont toujours
meilleures quand on les prépare en
famille
non car c'était
amusez vous en souhaitant la préparation
mélanger avec beaucoup d'amour
et une pincée de sourire laissez lever
et enfin décorer avec le délicieuse
touche de gourmandise parce que nutella
ajoute toujours quelque chose d'unique
nutella c'est si bon d'être ensemble est
très beau ça s'appelle et goulet mais
ouais madagh nébuleux farouche confond
pas avec un autre mot gk rien ce qu'on
mange
l'herbe est en ce moment retrouver dans
le happy meal le macm finnegan cheese et
pour votre prochain mac do en famille
fait délivrer
dès 1996 on a supprimé les sacs
plastique à usage unique de nos caisses
20 ans devant la loi et 5 c'est un
milliard de sacs en bois aujourd'hui on
va encore plus loin
on remplace tous les sacs plastiques de
nos caisses par les cinq ans toile de
jute recyclables échangeables acquis et
pim 7000 tonnes de plastique en moins
le nouveau geste pour les emplettes et
pour la planète leclerc lance les sacs
en toile de jute disponible dès
maintenant dans une claire
[Musique]
qu'est le prochain
votre programme avec la cie fidjienne
point fr gaines amincissantes qui a filé
sculpter votre silhouette classifie
deviennent point fr votre programme avec
le groupe rodin retraite prévoyance
assurance vie groupe rodin penser votre
épargne ce soir dans balances ton post
émission spéciale après le lancement par
cyril hanouna du mouvement protège tes
potes ce week end dans le but d'alerter
les jeunes face au co vidé à la deuxième
bas qui s'installe en france plusieurs
personnalités se sont mobilisées sur les
réseaux sociaux pour sensibiliser la
population protège ses potes ce soir
gabriel attal porte parole du
gouvernement sera en plateau face au
jeune français nous avons une
transparence absolue sur cette épidémie
après les nouvelles annonces drastiques
dans de nombreuses régions en france le
gouvernement a retenu pour ces
départements rouge plusieurs seuils
d'alert auxquels correspondent
différents niveaux de mesures suite à
une hausse massive des cas de corona
virus en quelques semaines on se
rapproche dangereusement d'un
confinement certains jeunes sont pointés
du doigt car jugé trop fêtard et
irresponsable
[Applaudissements]
mais certains se sentent aux siens
compris ce soir ils seront avec nous
qu'il soit influenceurs youtuber
entrepreneurs sportifs lycéens étudiants
barman restaurateurs jeunes employés ou
patrons de salles de sport ils poseront
toutes leurs questions sans aucun tabou
à gabriel attal retrouver ensuite
balance compost l'after eric naulleau et
ses éditorialistes reviendront sur le
débat alors que plusieurs politiques
sous-entendent avant de faire marche
arrière qu'un potentiel re confinement
est envisageable ces ménages sont pas on
pourrait se retrouver dans une situation
proche de celle qu'on a connue au
printemps mais nous ne voulons pas à
confiner le pays de ne voulons pas les
chroniqueurs se poseront une question
faut-il craindre un confinement balances
ton post ça commence maintenant
[Applaudissements]
lorsqu'on passe votre rendez vous
la police
un petit peu particulière ce soir est
extrêmement attendu
ça a été commentée sur les réseaux
sociaux toute la journée tout le monde
attend parce qu on a aussi les
chroniqueurs un petit peu spéciaux ce
soir on a bien sûr nos chroniqueurs
qu'on connaît il ya karim zéribi et la
valette déléguée des autres pour arriver
tout à l'heure et c'est vrai que ce soir
on voulait s'adressait bien sûr avoué
s'adresser aussi aux plus jeunes qui
nous regardent
parce que ce soir on veut des réponses
et beaucoup de français veulent des
réponses sur ce qui va se passer je vais
remercier parce que ça va ça va tanguer
ce soir ça va secouer
il est face à vous c'est le secrétaire
d'état auprès du premier ministre porte
parole du gouvernement gabriela talent
merci d'être là gabriel attal 31 ans
vous êtes le plus jeune ministre de
l'histoire de la vème république
déjà voilà c'est serré que c'est c'est
incroyable un premier encore premier
record exactement député la république
en marge des hauts-de-seine depuis 2017
et ce soir c'est vrai qu'on a énormément
de questions alors vous posez toutes vos
questions bien entendu en direct sur les
réseaux sociaux
on va essayer de les relayer le plus
possible ce soir on a également un lycée
dans le public voilà qui va pouvoir
réagir également et puis on a plein de
gens qui voulaient réagir on a des gens
que vous connaissez certainement
beaucoup
il ya déjà brudy gaubert série moment
ses stars
un des plus grands basketteurs amiens
oscars depuis cet ami premier 4 convient
de déclarer en nba et ça a été difficile
pour vous je le sais rudy parce que
c'est vrai que voilà ça a été une
aventure incroyable j'ai eu de la fièvre
vous avez perdu le goût l'odorat pendant
plusieurs mois vous récupérez
progressivement et vous voulez montrer
que même en faisant 2 m 16
vous faisiez fêté et vous posiez m né au
moment de sport et on peut malgré tout
tomber malade on est protégés de rien et
pour vous avez choisi de venir ce soir
rudy bas je pense que cela parce que
c'est mon gars merci merci rudy on
aurait plus important est important est
ce que vous voulez ce soit on veut faire
passer un message aux jeunes qui nous
regardent et un message d'urgence dans
cette émission c'est très important de
faire passer ce message d'urgence
on a avec nous julia layani et élise
goldfarb 4,420 qui brise les codes et
montre les fans vous avez énormément
d'abonnés merci d'être avec nous à les
poser toutes les questions aussi
et vous allez réveiller toutes les
questions bien sûr de deux de vos fans
alors on a je vous dis c'est la plus
grande star du moment et je le pense
vraiment voilà c'est just ryad merci
quand deux jours
d'abonnés sur un ca il passera les trois
lions sur twitter en octobre 2 millions
sur snapshot vous êtes un énorme
phénomène et on voulait absolument vous
soyez avec nous ce soir parce que votre
parole elle porte énormément et ce soir
il faut faire passer un message en
direct dans balances ton poste avec le
porte parole du gouvernement
merci just riyad est là aussi on a de la
chance bah oui la chance là on a le
porte parole
on va lui poser les questions qu'on
allait poser frère un non mais c'est
vrai vous avez des questions posées
parce que tout le monde se pose des
questions on en a besoin de savoir où on
en peut plus sûr d'un médecin
spécialiste en santé publique et
épidémiologiques 32 35 ans et le docteur
martin blachon qui va vous avez des
questions également et vous aurez
également des réponses à nous donner on
a six linky est là dix neuf ans
influence aussi la série les frontières
énormément de questions à poser si on à
amine le playboy
il y aura énormément de questions vous
allez voir comment ça va se passer vous
pouvez poser toutes vos questions à
notre porte parole du gouvernement tout
à l'heure olivier ferrand a donné son
point de presse hebdomadaire il a fait
plusieurs déclarations on reviendra
dessus juste gabriela talent ce soir les
téléspectateurs
ils ont compris qu'ils avaient une
urgence moi j'ai entendu dire qu'on
avait maintenant une dizaine de jours
pour vraiment effectuer les bons gestes
et peut-être sauvé 1re confinement est
ce que c'est vrai cette affaire est-ce
qu'on est sur le bon chemin
ou est-ce qu'on est sur un chemin qui va
nous mener un confinement il ya beaucoup
de gens qui parlent d'un long
confinement pour les vacances de la
toussaint ccd question tout le monde se
pose
je suis sûr que ces questions vont être
posées vous vous posez c'est la question
que vous les posez également je suis sur
vos autour de la table est-ce qu'on peut
répondre clairement à cette question
aujourd'hui ou pas parce qu'on peut dire
d'abord c'est qu'il ya une situation qui
est préoccupante en france qui est
préoccupante dans le monde entier
puisque le virus a repris dans beaucoup
de pays dans le monde mais qui est
préoccupante en france parce qu'il
circule circule beaucoup chez des
personnes âgées et parce qu'on voit une
augmentation des cas graves qui arrivent
à l'hôpital en réanimation et des décès
aussi mais ce qu'on peut dire aussi
moi je pense que c'est toujours
important d'avoir de l'espoir sinon
seraient pas là en train d'en parler
c'est qu'on peut encore prendre le virus
de vitesse parce que le virus
aujourd'hui ils circulent trois fois
moins vite qu'ils circulaient au
printemps dernier dans la première vague
en printemps dernier une personne qui
attrapait le col vide en moyenne elles
contaminé trois personnes aujourd'hui en
moyenne
elle contamine un peu plus d'une
personne parce que les françaises sont
mobilisés parce qu'ils ont été
responsables parce que tout le monde
porte le masque au travail a le masque à
l'école masse dans la rue parce qu'on
fait attention aux distances et parce
que voilà il ya cette responsabilité
chez les français et finalement il faut
peut-être encore un peu plus d'efforts
notamment dans certains endroits pour
arriver à faire reculer ce virus et ce
qui est certain c'est que si là il n'y a
pas cette mobilisation dans les têtes
deux semaines qui viennent
d'accord ça sera peut-être difficile
d'inverser la tendance et moi j'ai pas
envie que cette émission dans quelques
semaines ou dans quelques mois on sera
obligé de la faire depuis notre canapé
chacun sur zoom nous ce qu'on aimerait
c'est que ce soit en fasse avancer les
choses et qu'on va se passer les bons
messages et se soit pas du bullshit j'ai
envie de dire c'est à dire que les
français se mobilisent et qu'après on se
disait c'est trop
ça a été pas ce soir je pense que tous
ici ils veulent des vraies réponses et
de vraies solutions c'est-à-dire pour
savoir est-ce qu'on peut sauver 1 re
confinement pas qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire c'est vrai que vous vouliez ce
soir gabriel voilà et des jeunes parce
qu'aujourd'hui ce sont les jeunes qui
portent qui pose le plus problème parce
que ils sentent et je les comprends
moi je vois gg voilà vous avez tous des
potes voilà qui ont peut-être qu'ils ont
peut-être été touché par la cobi 19 et
vous dit ouais bon bah ça va il est
resté un jour à la maison et puis ils
allaient bien réponse est pas rendu
compte mais c'est eux qui posent
problème parce que derrière ils sont en
fait ils respectent pas les gestes
barrière est ce qui fait que le virus
continue à progresser
d'abord parce que je veux dire c'est que
les jeunes ça a été des héros du
confinement et de ce qu'ils
s'adressaient au printemps dernier on a
vu des jeunes dans les hôpitaux ce soit
des internes des jeunes médecins
on a vu des jeunes qui travaillent dans
les supermarchés qui sont aller bosser
la boule au ventre parce que ils avaient
peur et qu'on savait encore pas grand
chose de cette épidémie on a vu des
jeunes qui étaient confinés chez eux
mais qui ont aidé des personnes âgées
qui habitent dans leur immeuble en
allant faire leurs courses et moi je
pense que les jeunes ils ont la
possibilité d'être les héros de ce
moment là celui on va empêcher la
deuxième vague comme celle qu'on a vécue
au printemps de survenir et c'est vrai
que pour ça il faut une mobilisation
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui le virus il
circule le plus et il a le plus circulé
ces dernières semaines chez les jeunes
parce que il ya eu l'été parce que
peut-être qu'il ya eu un peu de
relâchement et en même temps moi je je
je n'aurais jamais je n'aurais jamais
donnerait jamais de leçon de morale
cette épidémie ce virus il est nouveau
on le découvre tous les quelques mois
les jeunes et tous les français il
entendait les scientifiques les membres
du gouvernement alors expliqué qu' il
fallait pas porter de masque aujourd'hui
le masque qu'il est devenu obligatoire
la recherche avance les choses elle
changé donc je n'aurai pas de jugement
de morale je dirais pas que ça circule à
cause de ce que je dis c'est que s'ils
se mobilisent et ben on peut terrasser
le virus et c'est un peu le message que
je veux faire passer ce soir aussi
répondre aux questions évidemment alors
peut-être ici à des questions très
précises technique jean la tête pas
toutes les réponses mais en tout cas
j'essaierai de vous vous dire on veut
aller et comment on veut y aura plein de
questions soit on apportera toutes les
réponses sont fondés sur un an fin le
porteur du gouvernement essaiera
d'apporter le maximum de réponses et
surtout de faire passer les messages qui
me poser une première question ici
autour de la table allez-y oui agathon
groupe a déjà merci
voir accepter notre notre invitation
c'est un honneur de vous recevoir ici où
vous avez je pense beaucoup de courage
parce que ça va sans doute un petit peu
compliqué je vais commencer la question
que vous apposez syrie dans
l'introduction d'un malheureusement pas
été répondu clairement donc je vais la
reformuler est-ce que 1re confinement en
france sur le territoire sur un pont
national est en discussion en ce moment
au gouvernement non aujourd'hui on ne
discute pas du fait de confiner à court
terme et on se dit pas on verra confier
comme je l'entends il ya des rumeurs qui
circulent je sais les bois de sapin voir
ma famille mes soeurs ma mère m'envoient
des messages j'ai reçu un message d'une
copine qui me dit qu'a priori on recopie
dray le 15 octobre et c'est tout ça
c'est faux y a pas de décision de
confinement alors pourquoi en question
maintenant mais enfin pourquoi il ya une
urgence alors si vous me demandez si je
peux exclure absolument que dans les
prochains mois on devra revenir à une
situation comme celle qu'on a connue au
printemps dernier je peux je peux pas
dire oui parce que tous ceux qui se sont
exprimées pendant la première vague qui
ont voulu exclure des choses en disant
ça ça arrivera jamais ça sera jamais
obligatoire
ça sera jamais nécessaire ba s'est vite
ils ont été démenties par les faits
parce qu'il ya une part
d'imprévisibilité il ya des choses qu'on
ne peut pas prévoir mais ce que je peux
vous dire la seule chose qui est sûre
c'est que tout ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui
tout ce qu'on demande aux français comme
effort tout ce qu'on demande aux jeunes
comme est forte on le fait pour éviter
d'avoir à confiner le pays parce que
leur confinement
ces mauvais évidemment pour notre
économie mais pas seulement c'est
mauvais pour les jeunes qui doivent
aller à l'école qui doivent apprendre
c'est mauvais pour les gens qui sont
seuls qui sont isolés on a vu ce que ça
a donné en termes d'isolement notamment
pour certaines personnes âgées
moi je suis élu local j'ai vu des
personnes âgées qui ont été isolés
pendant le confinement seuls qui ont
pris cinq en cinq mois
parce que c'est hyper dur ce qui est ce
qui a été vécu donc elle veut empêcher
seront confinement gabriela talent quand
on parle de re confinement est ce que si
dans un mois on n'a pas fait le
nécessaire
est ce que ce serait un confinement
comme on a pu le connaître la saison
dernière
ou bien ce sera un grand confinement où
j'ai entendu parler d'un long
confinement partiel c'est-à-dire que les
gens pourraient aller au travail et
rentrer directement chez eux ou voile
arisée voilà territorialisée est ce que
ce serait et c est ce qu on serait dans
quel type d'euros confirmant nous ce
qu'on fait depuis le déconfinement en
fait au printemps dernier on a choisi de
confier tout le pays pourquoi parce
qu'on avait aucune visibilité sur le
virus n'avait pas les capacités de test
on savait pas comment ils circulaient
circulez aujourd'hui ça a changé on fait
des tests on est capable de voir où est
ce qui circule plus qu'ailleurs et donc
pour répondre à votre question on fait
le choix de faire les choses de manière
graduée et territorialisée dire qu'on ne
prend pas les mêmes mesures partout en
france parce que le virus ne circule pas
de la même manière partout et que y'a
pas de raison de demander les mêmes
mesures et de mettre les mêmes
restrictions sur des gens qui sont dans
un territoire où le virus circule peu ou
pas du tout et des gens dans des
territoires où le virus circule
énormément donc ça sera deux manières de
toute façon toutes nos mesures être
songer sont faites de manière
territorialise est-ce que vous avez
conscience qui avant d'en voir tout à
l'heure d'été des témoignages de patrons
de bars de patrons de salles de sport de
personnes qui travaillent dans des des
boîtes de nuit dans des discothèques
ce que vous avez conscience
qu'aujourd'hui la les françaises disais
moi j'en ai eu énormément au téléphone
en corse après midi qui me disait si on
est confiné
c'est terminé pour nous c'est fini on
met la clé sous la porte
on tout ce qu'on a bâtie pendant 10 15
20 ans et ben s'est réduit à néant
est-ce que vous en avez conscience est
ce que cette décision vous allez prendre
en fonction de ce qui va se passer dans
les 15 prochains jours vous allez
apprendre en ayant bien ça en tête quand
je vois ce qui se passe à marseille
actuellement on a eu le témoignage d'un
restaurateur la semaine dernière qui
était qui disait voilà je suis j'ai voué
toute ma vie à mon bar restaurant et
aujourd'hui je vais me retrouver à la
rue parce que voilà j'ai fait plus que
ça bon j'ai eu des gens voilà qui qui
ont des salles de sport qui disent on
peut alors legendry discothèque c'est
une catastrophe les gens dans
l'événementiel est-ce que vous avez
s'entêtait ce que est ce qu'aujourd'hui
et on sait aujourd'hui la vraie question
c'est est ce qu'il faut privilégier
l'économie ou la santé
on peut pas faire des deux apparemment
ça c'est ce que vous avez essayé de
combiner mais qu'est ce que vous dites
parce que je sais que même des échos que
j'ai dit je pouvais me dire que tu es tu
dis une bêtise mais des échos que j'ai
sur le gouvernement il y en a qui disent
il faut privilégier la santé d'autres
qui préfèrent privilégier l'économie
même au sein du gouvernement parce que
c'est vrai que nous avancent à tâtons
vous savez pas trop vraiment voilà vers
quoi aller est ce que j'en avais
conscience est ce que vous c'est quoi
votre espoir aujourd'hui
bon moi d'abord pour répondre à votre
question est ce qu'on a conscience de la
détresse de ceux qui sont restaurateurs
de ceux qui t'ont patron de bar patrick
salles de sport évidemment qu'on en a
conscience et je crois que ce soir il va
y avoir des attaques l'eau si tous les
gens du spectacle
catastrophe je crois que ce soit
réveillé bordas jurignac notamment de
jeunes qui m'ont d'ailleurs barlan
restos et moi ça me touche d'autant plus
que l'on entend en permanence des gens
nous expliquer que les jeunes ils ont
pas envie de travailler que les jeunes y
glande là parce que c'est justement des
jeunes qui ont monté leur affaire tu as
envie de bosser qui ont envie de réussir
et qui ont envie de de travailler tout
simplement et donc oui on en a
conscience maintenant le président il a
toujours dit une chose très claire
depuis le début de cette crise c'est
d'abord on fait tout pour protéger la
santé des français et ça c'est l'honneur
de la france ne pas sacrifier la santé
de ses concitoyens sur l'autel de
l'économie
il ya des pays qui ont pu faire ce choix
là mais n'ont souvent regretté ils sont
souvent revenu dessus et ils ont fini
par prendre des mesures restrictives qui
avaient un impact sur l'économie
et ensuite la deuxième chose c'est que
évidemment doit soutenir notre économie
la france c'est un des pays dans le
monde si ce n'est le pays qui a le plus
soutenu son économie qui a plus soutenu
les entreprises qui a fait de chômage
partiel vous allez commencer à l'arrivée
vous avez continué à le faire si
évidemment on confine évidemment qu'on
fait un film à la fois la question
gabriel et joue moi je vous pose les
questions de taille voilà vous allez
vous poser d'autres questions pas mais
je pose des questions que tout le monde
se pose il ya plein de gens qui disent
oui mais où vous allez trouver les sous
on était déjà en difficulté avant de co
vide avant la qu'ovide on vous avait
fait une aide qui va coûter énormément
dessous vous allez re pôvres faire
peut-être une aide si on est confiné
comment on fait alors d'abord on a pu
effectivement faire ses dépenses parce
qu'on a été responsable depuis trois ans
depuis trois ans il ya une politique
responsable pour pas dépenser n'importe
comment vous savez c'est comme une
famille vous faites mais des économies
de côté en cas de coup dur
c'est un peu ce qui s'est passé première
chose deuxième chose on a été chercher
de l'argent en europe
ça c'est le président de la république
qui s'est mobilisé qui allait voir tous
les chefs d'état européens qui leur a
dit m
et s'ils ont levé de l'argent en europe
c'est dire si on demandait à l'europe
d'emprunter elle même plutôt que ce soit
les pays membres qui empruntent pour
distribuer de l'argent au pays et
l'europe elle va se rembourser non pas
en allant demander de l'argent aux pays
membres
mais en allant taxer les google amazon
facebook qui paye par leurs impôts en
allant à taxer des produits qui viennent
de pays comme la chine par exemple qui
respectent pas nos standards
environnementaux bref en allant chercher
d'autres ressources
et troisièmement c'est une dette qui va
être remboursée sur du très long terme
et parce qu'on investit on y reviendra
peut-être mais on fait un plan de
relance 100 milliards d'euros pour avoir
un coup de fouet sur l'économie pour que
l'activité elles repartent parce qu'on
investit parce qu'il est hors l'activité
économique ça va permettre de
bourse est aussi cette date just ryad je
voulais te dire un truc c'est vrai qu'il
ya déjà des aides qui sont donnés mais
la france ne peut pas aider tous les
français il ya plein de gens qui même
avec les aides
bah c'est pas assez il n'arrive pas à
finir les mois la france elle aide tous
ceux qui en ont besoin dans cette crise
si on n'avait pas aidé il ya des
milliers si ce n'est des centaines de
milliers d'entreprises qui serait
effondré il ya des millions de salariés
qui aurait été licencié parce qu'on
n'aurait pas fait de chômage partiel
chômage partiel je crois qu'au maximum
ça accompagné près de 20 millions de
salariés
car c'est les salariés qui soudain coup
son billet de payer par l'état pour
éviter que les entreprises et à les
licencier
on a distribué des masques gratuitement
pour ceux qui sont les plus modestes et
qui n'ont pas la possibilité de se payer
un masque donc on regarde ceux qui sont
les plus dans la difficulté et on
apporte des aides c'est le fameux quoi
qu'il en coûte que le président de la
république
il a dit je trouve de manière assez
imagé il a dit quand votre maison elle
brûle vous comptez pas le nombre de
seaux d'eau que vous déversez pour
éteindre un incendie
voilà bien sûr qu'il faut être
responsable bien sûr que à l'avenir il
va falloir être responsable mais je
viens d'expliquer comment est-ce qu'on
allait rembourser cette dette et donc on
a une trajectoire pour le faire alors on
a deux le docteur martin blachier quitte
avec nos médecins spécialistes en santé
publique et vidéo mais équipe
épidémiologique vous avez 35 ans ce que
vous avez une question à poser à notre
porte parole je voudrais réagir sur
l'image qui vient d'édicter intéressant
le jeté des seaux d'eau sur sur la
maison qui brûle
je voudrais dire aussi qu'il faut faire
attention aux braises qui reste quand là
on vient de jeter des seaux d'eau parce
qu'il faut bien se rendre compte qu'en
fait une grosse fête peut être
responsable d'une reprise épidémique aux
etats unis ils ont fait un rassemblement
de motards les bikers harley davidson
ils ont fait une soirée dans des bars
qu'ils ont été responsables de 200000
contamination dans le massachusetts
je pense que c'est important de voir ça
et en inde ils sont en train de le voir
aussi c'est à dire que les 18 25 ans en
fait à eux tout seuls ils relancent
l'épidémie parce qu'en fait c'est de là
que sa part c'est de là que sa part on
fait des fêtes
ça fait des contaminations et après ça
remonte l'estrade d'âge petit à petit
comme ça et donc en fait suffit d'éviter
quelques événements vraiment des grosses
fêtes et déjà réduit énormément le
risque que ça reparte et en fait
quelques événements comme ça qui sont un
peu responsables peuvent mettre tout le
pays
vraiment dans la panade comme on est
aujourd'hui c'est à dire confinement les
bars et les restaurants fermés et tous
et c'est vrai et ça on le voit dans les
chiffres
cette génération-là hélène rey ce
concept est ce pas dire qu'elle peut
or de vie sociale on peut faire des
soirées avec des amis on peut faire
plein de choses mais les choses qu'on
peut pas faire c'est les grosses soirées
à 1000 personnes parce que ça ces bombes
épidémique faut qu'on va falloir qu'on
évite de faire ça pendant les six mois
un an jusqu'à ce qu'on ait une solution
en six mois un an ça jusqu'à ce qu'on a
un vaccin mais là les et des américains
et viennent de dire on avait des supers
vaccins entre badis allait sortir en
octobre ils sont tous en train de dire
ouais ouais peut-être au printemps si on
a un bon vaccin de vaccins se sera pas
due aux noces sera pas tout de suite
donc voilà va falloir se responsabiliser
jeu va falloir inventer nouvelle vie
pendant l'année qui vient
mais les grosses soirées étudiantes les
grosses fêtes privées ou la sécession
lors du match ouais
difficile alors on à andré da silva dans
le public 28 ans travaillé dans la
restauration à 5 ou cas une question à
poser
andré parce que lui il sait salon bett
tout seul à lisieux pouvez vous lever
andré bonsoir andré merci d'être là beau
gosse un bras j'ai trouvé cinq ans dans
la restauration et du coup je me suis
lancé dans l'événementiel et j'ai
commencé à organiser des grosses soirées
on va dire dans des lieux assez récent
on va dire et sans forcément avec les
gestes barrières et du coup ma question
c'était quand elle regretté ça vous le
regrettez ou pas je regrette par les
biens dans le micro au même genou
justement c'est ça c'est ça le gros
problème ce soir
voilà et c'est pour ça que gabriella
talent est là aussi ce soir c'est serré
que ces discours qu'on entend on est
jeune on a envie de faire la fête et
votre question elle est simple vous
voulez dire vous dites vous allez aller
où faire la fête maintenant que c'est ça
c'est ce qui vous est exactement ça mais
je me suis dit on peut faire autre chose
c'est par exemple les gens qui prient de
l'avion par exemple il faut qu'ils
apportent un test un test du covin
négatif de -2 3 jours et c'est ce qu'on
pourrait faire exactement pour nos
soirées apporter un test négatif de -2 3
jours et avec des gestes barrières bien
évidemment c'est à dire benoît est
obligatoire
après les gestes barrière ça on pourra
pas mais dans tous les cas les gens
seront négatifs au co vite donc on
pourrait faire des soirées des grosses
soirées sans quelques problèmes
logiquement après je ne sais pas vous le
dire lui lui
on a tous envie de revivre comme on
vivait avant on a tous marre de porter
le masque quand on est obligé de le
porter on a tous marre de ne pas pouvoir
faire la bise ses amis de ne pas pouvoir
prendre dans les bras ce qu'on aime
c'est pénible et on a tous envie de même
en gpo être au gouvernement j'ai 31 ans
je me dois faire la fête on a tous envie
de ça va donner
pendant un temps il va falloir ne plus
faire la fête comme on la faisait avant
ça veut pas dire comme l'a dit le
docteur qu' on peut pas se voir entre
amis on peut se voir entre amis si on
respecte les gestes barrières on peut
avoir une vie sociale
évidemment mais les grosses fêtes où
tout le monde est massé mais honnêtement
le géant j'entends le livre sur les
tests je suis pas sûr que ça soit
protecteur et que ça empêche qui est des
contaminations
d'abord parce que pouvait être un faux
négatifs comme on dit ça peut toujours
arriver je vois le docteur qui touche la
tête
ensuite parce que vous pouvez toujours
avoir votre tête attrapez le coronavirus
après avoir fait voter est bref il faut
être très costaud new précautionneux et
donc pour être précautionneux qu'est ce
qu'on fait on regarde quels sont les
principaux moyens par lesquels le virus
il se transmet et le fait est que quand
on est dans un lieu bondé quand on est
dans un lieu clos sans masque où en plus
on a une proximité les uns avec les
autres
voilà il ya des clusters de
contamination c'est à dire que le virus
il se diffuse et encore plus quand il ya
des grosses soirées on parle beaucoup de
marseille mais je suis allé à marseille
cet été
pendant mes vacances je suis allé le 17
août faire un papa en vacances mais je
suis allé en déplacement là-bas pour
rencontrer les élus et pour aller voir
les gens qui font les tests parce que
dès le 17 août
on savait qu'il se passait quelque chose
à marseille moi j'y suis allé aussi pour
alerter pour dire faites attention à
l'époque y avait des soirées sur des
roues stop qui réunissait plus de 1000
jeunes 2000 jeunes 3000 jeunes gens n'a
fermé ses bars dès cette époque là parce
que voyait que c'était des arrivées
aussi des clusters de contamination
alors à paris aussi c'est vrai alors il
ya eu julia c'est élise au comédia
julien aussi qu'ils voulaient poser que
tu allais dans leur église bâtie moi
j'ai juste une question
enfin ces questions en fait je comprends
rien c'est à dire que je sais pas si
j'ai le droit de faire une teuf avec 10
personnes avec 25 personnes
avec 50 personnes qu'on me dit que j'ai
pas droit d'en faire mais de l'autre
côté fin mai en soirée à la fashion week
il ya des défilés dans tous les sens et
les gens font des afters je sais je dis
je des films beaucoup également
mais aussi
je vois des fêtes clandestines
franchement il ya des tofs clandestine
partout dans paris mais genre des rêves
on est des centaines de personnes et il
se passe rien le puy du fou est ouvert
mais alors derrière on dit non ne fait
pas ce dîner auquel j'ai une question
vraiment concrètes
samedi soir mon meilleur ami enfin notre
meilleur ami avec julie a fait son
anniversaire
alors qu'est-ce il y en a d'autres qui
ont des grands mères qui fait un goûter
si oui mais j'aime les gens de notre âge
ils ont vraiment cette question bien sûr
monsieur loyal anniversaire est ce qu'il
l'organisateur pas déjà c'est quoi y'a
combien de personnes ces 110 personnes
dans un appart parisien voilà on
feuilletait banon en fait non c'est pas
sérieux de faire une fille c'est
d'ailleurs comme ça qu'on se laisse
alors sérieux il faut lui dire et il
faut pas tout mélanger
vous étiez vous donner des exemples là
notamment le puy du fou ou un défilé de
mode
comment ils sont les gens au puy du fou
devant un spectacle où pendant un défilé
de mode
comment ils sont ok ils sont assis
masqué ils sont assis et masqués est ce
que dans la teuf de votre pote pour son
anniversaire
vous allez être tranquillement tout à
l'heure si sur les canapés masqué par le
nord la soirée une panne ont tout alors
là je rebondis là dessus et gabriela
talent sûr au cinéma pour minorer les
gens ils sont assis ils peuvent être
masquées et ils généralement ils parlent
pas pour nos films et c'est vrai qu'il
ya l'industrie du cinéma qui en grosse
difficulté il va se passer quoi avec les
salles de cinéma belge salles de cinéma
sont ouverts ou mails vont rester
ouvertes ce même si parce que jusque là
c'est vrai qu'ils arrivent au problème
il ya plein de gens qui disaient le
cinéma le théâtre et un rien trop vers
qui on parle pas mais parce qu'un
protocole sanitaire parce que les gens
ils sont assis mais syrte leur masque si
le protocole sanitaire au théâtre ben
voila j'ai moi j'ai mon pote qui at elle
mal et il a dû annuler sa tournée qui
embrasse gad prochainement c'est vrai
que moi j'ai touché que j'ai eus german
acloque hier j'ai tous mes potes voilà
qui sont en train d'annuler leur tournée
il ya matt pokora tombera ce math qui a
aussi annulé sa tournée parce que en
vrai dans un spectacle on parle pas on
écoute on écoute si on respectait
distance et si on a un masque pourquoi
les salles de spectacle et ils doivent
annuler leur tournée pour enfin il ya
deux sujets parce que l'aller les
tournées dont vous parlez oui parce que
c'est des très gros échec aux événements
plusieurs milliers de personnes
oui mais là c'est vrai on a dit qu'on a
fixé une limite qui était à 5000 qui est
maintenant à 1000 pour pâques et ses
gros événement parce que là ça
as tellement de monde d'accord que l'on
se dit qu'il peut apparaître même s'ils
sont assis et qui avait voilà ça il ya
toujours un bon vous allez rentrer dans
le vous allez faire la queue vous allez
être dans un couloir bondé pour accéder
aux poses des questions de tête à tête
mais c'est vrai ça passait question bête
c'est que les questions que les gens se
posent aussi je reçois plein de
questions très concrètes sûrement
instagram sur mon twitter les gens
permanent peut poser question
j'essaye d'y répondre et juste pour
répondre à la question de tout à l'heure
j'ai entendu ce que vous disiez sur les
rêves les soirées clandestines organisé
ça c'est inacceptable c'est inacceptable
et ceux qui organisent ces soirées
clandestines sont totalement
irresponsables
ils peuvent être condamnés on organise
des contrôles je crois qu'il ya eu près
de 10000 contrôle d'établissements
recevant du public qui ont été fait
jusqu'à maintenant est ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que je pense qu'on va
accroître les sanctions pour ceux qui
organise ce type de soirées
clandestinement parce que va demander à
tout le monde est responsable et avoir
des gens qui organisent des soirées
toujours en secret où rien n'est
respecté mais alors est-ce qu'on doit
juste se crée un club d'amis qu'on garde
genre on se dit tout le temps c'est plus
dans ma vie c'est une très bonne
question parce que il ya plusieurs pays
et notamment la belgique qui ont mis en
place ce qu'ils appellent une bulle
social dire qu'ils ont dit aussi toi
leurs citoyens en fait vous allez
choisir j'ai pu si ces cinq ou dix mille
10 personnes que vous allez voir
régulièrement
et tant qu'il y aura là le virus vous
verrez sur peu de personnes sont dehors
la raison en fait un bourge ce qu'on dit
depuis le début c'est il faut réduire le
nombre de ses contacts faut voir moins
de monde mais c'est vrai que si chacun
se dit bah je me crée ma bulle
avec 5 10 meilleures années la dunette
plaît messieurs l'est on aurait pu
éviter ce avec des riffs parallèle il ya
une écoute là avec la fermeture des
établissements des bars et des
restaurants ya une économie de la partie
parallèle qui s'est monté on aurait pu
l'éviter
peut-être qu'on aurait pu renforcer les
restrictions par en termes de fermeture
mais en termes de conditions avec des
masques fortin vraiment obligatoire des
contrôles plus stricts etc
les patrons d'établissements étaient
demandeurs en plus de travailler avec
les les services de l'état pour
justement qu'on évite ce qui est en
train de se passer est là avec la
fermeture à 22 30
on se retrouve avec moi je n'ai jamais
reçu autant dans vite de fait dans des
appartements et c'est comme ça qu'on va
peut-être lancé l'épidémie bon c'est ça
qui m'inquiète c'est qu'en fermant d'un
côté les bars et les restos on pénalise
justement ces établissements-là et de
l'autre côté on va peut-être lancé
l'épidémie aussi de cette manière là
bon alors d'abord mais je pense que les
fêtes clandestines
c'est moins dans les restos et les bars
que dans les discothèques pour le coup
qu'on a à faire mais il assume de fermer
on se dit qu'elle aurait pu avoir lieu
et moi j'assume totalement cette
décision je sais qu'elle est difficile
pour ceux qui tiennent une discothèque
je sais pas si on aura ce soir qui vont
s'exprimer
je sais que pour ceux qui ont une boîte
c'est très compliqué parce qu'on leur a
bien d'être fermé des pays qui avaient
fait le choix ne pas fermer leur boîte
ou de les rouvrir avant l'été mais ils
ont tous un truc en commun c'est que
finalement ils sont venus de suez qui
les ont fermé parce que là on voit bien
comment des personnes dans un lieu bondé
alors oui on peut dire
ils vont tous porter le masque enfin on
est tous j'espère enfin je crois
ici déjà allé en boîte dans notre vie on
sait très bien ce qui se passe à partir
de là rien dire puisque les autres quand
on est un peu bourré bas qu'est ce qu'on
fait bon évidemment est-ce qu'on va
garder son masque est ce qu'on va
continuer à appliquer les gestes
barrière je pense pas voilà c'est pour
ça que les pays les ont refermé et des
pays qui ont testé des formules hybrides
oui disait on laisse la boîte ouverte
mais vous êtes obligée de danser à 6 on
a vu la limite de taille au disco ces
assises nous regardons la question des
bars lounge offre on a geoffroy
justement qu'est patron de bar qui
patron d'un bar et d'un restaurant il
évite à part il a 30 ans et geoffroy il
a une question bon soir à geoffroy sa
merci d'être là merci il paraît qu'en
plus vous connaissez le hasard total on
a on a travaillé ensemble il ya quelques
années sur paris alors que vous étiez
son patron non mon collègue à l'été
collègues ils étaient ils étaient
étudiants de mémoire et faisait travail
et serveurs avec vous oui j'étais
serveurs pendant mes études en réseau et
geoffroy et et le barman et on rentre on
ici je suis ton fils est champion
s'étaient pas revues de voilà c'est
aussi des retrouvailles dans cette
émission sur un sujet comme ça c'est
intéressant après alors vous vous vous
êtes vous êtes en galère on va pas se
mentir geoffroy a perdu quinze mille
euros par mois et par établissement
pendant le confinement ouais c'est c'est
énorme et c'est pas mieux depuis mais
voilà quel est votre question pour notre
porte parole et qu'est ce qu'elle est
votre message à faire passer
alors parce que c'est vrai que tous les
patrons de bars et de restaurants
aujourd'hui on va le dire ils sont au
bout du rouleau
c'est compliqué effectivement je vais
déjà commencer je t'ai de me faire
l'avocat du diable mais c'est vrai que
par les permis ont même été beaucoup
aidé financièrement et effectivement
peut-être avec l'argent de l'europe où
peu importe les débats kia mais ça a
peut-être quand même sauvé beaucoup
d'avoir été accompagnés c'est pas
suffisant
elle a beaucoup qui ont coulé je pense
aussi que les choix qui ont été faits il
fallait les faire bon ou mauvais on peut
faire des débats je pense que comme on
dit fallait peut-être avoir la force de
les poser sur la table pour pour pour
prendre des décisions
donc donc voilà maintenant moi le
problème qui aujourd'hui c'est que je
pense qu'on voit pas le bout on parlait
de six mois on parlait de 20 ans ça peut
être deux ans et les solutions qu'on a
aujourd'hui c'est c'est pas le futur
fermé quinze jours fermer à 22h ça va
faire rebaisser mais on sait qu'on ne
pourra pas s'en passer
ce faire des fêtes avec les amis on va
trouver des d'autres choses à faire et
ça va être une rustine qui va durer qui
va durer trois mois
et puis ça va repartir même si c'est
plus loin mais ça repartira toujours et
si c'est pour dans trois mois
refaire la même chose ça va pas aller on
peut pas perdre de l'argent on peut pas
dépenser
l'état peut pas dépenser de l'argent
pour aider ils peuvent pas y avoir 10 %
de 2,2 de restaurants de bars qui
ferment donc aujourd'hui moi je sais
quel est son intérêt ce qu'elle est est
ce qu'il ya une autre solution
et au lieu de taper sur les jeunes et
sur les gens dynamiques
est-ce qu'on peut pas essayer de
protéger de protéger les les gens plus
fragiles pour laisser vivre les autres
on sait qu'on en a moins de danger
d'être d'être de finir l'hôpital ou ou
de houe ou deux on peut transmettre lui
en transmet plus le virus mais on est
moins dangereux donc pourquoi pas
protéger les autres pour garder
l'économie pour garder notre vie
essentielle parce que si ces deux ans eh
bien on pourra pas continuer comme ça
alors la question de geoffroy c'est vrai
que c'est une question qu'on voit
beaucoup beaucoup circulé sur les
réseaux sociaux
pourquoi la question en résumé c'est
pourquoi ne pas confiner les plus de 65
ans les personnes les plus à risque sur
une période donnée c'est une question
qui revient énormément et est ce que
c'est une décision ou une solution qui a
été évoqué d'abord pour répondre à ta
question je te tutoie fait leur force
connaît pour répondre à la première
question sur sk une autre solution
s'il y avait une autre solution parfaite
miracle il ya un pays dans le monde qui
l'aurait trouvé pour l'instant il y en a
aucun qui l'a trouvé où tout le monde
cherche
tout le monde cherche la bonne solution
ensuite la deuxième question ce que je
comprends c'est est ce que finalement
tous ces efforts toutes ces contraintes
qu'on demande à tout le monde ça vole
c'est ce que finalement on se dirait pas
on va concentrer nos efforts et
uniquement mettre le paquet sur ceux qui
sont les plus à risque dans l'épidémie
et j'entends parfaitement cette logique
est d'ailleurs d'une certaine manière
c'est un peu ce qu'on fait ce que dans
les piliers de notre stratégie est le
fait d'avoir une protection maximum pour
les personnes les plus vulnérables
c'est-à-dire les personnes âgées et
c'est à dire les personnes qui ont ce
qu'on appelle des comorbidités donc ils
sont malades
par ailleurs mais ce n'est pas aussi
simple que ça malheureusement
aujourd'hui dans l'airé admis dans les
réanimations à paris vous avez entre 30
et 40 % des malades qui sont en
réanimation ça veut dire qu'ils ont des
formes très graves qui ont moins de 65
ans donc c'est pas vrai que c'est que
les et seniors les plus les public plus
âgé il y en a 30 à 40% qui ont moins de
60 go confiner les plus de 65 ans ça
servira de deuxième chose reconfirmer
les plus de 65 ans ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire enfin on leur dit de rester
chez eux c'est un peu ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui alors dix ans se protéger le
plus possible mais du coup si on pousse
la logique jusqu'au bout c'est quoi on
les enferme on les empêche non mais on
met des policiers devant leur maison
enfin j'arrive on parlait tout à l'heure
de l'isolément social des drames que ça
a eu il ya des gens qui ont les maladies
qui ont un d alzheimer qui ont des
maladies de parkinson on sait que l'
isolement ce que ça produirait assurent
eux ce serait peut-être encore pire que
le mal
et troisièmement c'est important de le
dire aussi parce que je pense que tout
le monde a fait des erreurs et peut-être
que nous n'a pas été suffisamment bon
sur certains points nous décrire les
messages qu'on a adressé aux jeunes sur
les quais attention on a beaucoup dit
les jeux ne sont pas à risque il peut
rien arriver aux jeunes c'est simple
c'est ce que on n'a pas suffisamment
fait mis en avant le fait qu'il ya des
jeunes qui font des formes peut-être pas
aussi grave que des personnes très âgées
mais des formes sévères je pense qu'on a
des exemples ici sur le plateau des gens
qui l'ont eue qui ont parfois garder des
séquelles qui plusieurs mois après
peuvent plus courir ont du mal à
respirer quand il monte un escalier ça
existe aujourd'hui dans le pays
donc ne pas considérer que ça
malheureusement c'est pas aussi simple
que ça mais il est encore une fois le
médecin peut-être peu rudy c'est vrai
que ruy voilà c'est un grand sportif est
en bonne santé et érudit qui a été un
des premiers cas de kovy déclaré en
aiguille et c'est vrai que vous avez été
très fatigué vous avez aimé plusieurs
mois pour récupérer un ça à peu de temps
c'est vrai que les premiers jours
c'était comme un coup de froid et à et
après bon j'ai testé positif pour la
saison été suspendu
donc on était à la maison j'étais à la
maison pendant plusieurs mois à sollac
city et c'est vrai que j'ai eu des
symptômes que j'avais jamais vu avant
dans ma vie donc c'était n'est pas aussi
la peur bien sûr bien sûr on sait pas ce
que c'est vraiment mais on voit plein de
choses sur internet et c'est donc ça
fait peur mais vous avez peur peut-être
de peut-être plus pouvoir voilà joue au
basket ou peut-être d'avoir un truc qui
qui s'aggrave
mais honnêtement je pensais même je
pensais même pas au basket à ce moment
là je sens que ma famille parce que ma
famille était en france mais aussi aux
états unis donc ma je pouvais pas voir
leurs familles en fête
et là je pensais surtout à oreille
commence à aller sur le long terme
est ce que j'allais récupérer puis bien
sûr pouvoir rejouer et bien sûr pouvoir
voir en famille just ryad ouais j'avais
une question ça d'un fou d'austrian sur
scène à une question il ya les salles de
sport eto'o qui ont fermé dans paris les
bars à partir de 22 heures etc
mais pourquoi on continue de laisser les
gens à l'école parce que c'est ça c'est
le cas aussi en fer blanc je fais des
questions qui me sont revenus le plus
souvent les gens me demandent quand je
comprends la question je disais tout à
l'heure que ce qu'on regardait avant
tout c'est comment est-ce que le virus
se transmet et quels sont les lieux où
il se transmet le plus se transmet le
plus dans des lieux qui sont fermées ou
fin je pars au dire tout ce que j'ai dit
tout à l'heure mais on n'a pas de
masquer votre le transmet par aérosol on
appelle ça c'est à dire par les
gouttelettes qu'on envoie dans une salle
de sport moi je suis plus abonnés une
salle de sport malheureusement mais je
les ai été vous faites des activités
physiques
porter a priori pas de masque et donc
vous envoyez des gouttelettes de la
sueur qui peuvent rester dans l'air un
certain temps c'est pas exactement
combien de temps encore peuvent rester
sur des objets qui peuvent contaminer
d'autres personnes c'est en fait alors
l'arrêter sur les salles de sport à
paris vient d'être suspendu là j'ai vu
sa réfection ans il ya le tribunal
admistratif de paris et celui de rennes
qui ont suspendu l'arrêté
les arrêtés qui prévoyait la fermeture
des salles deux ans ce qui veut dire
qu'elles vont être rouvertes samedi
alors je crois j'ai pas vu j'ai pas lu
exactement l'arrêter à paris mais je
crois qu'à rennes ça veut dire que pour
l'instant elles peuvent
ouvrir à paris je crois que non il donne
jusqu'à lundi au préfet pour préciser
les choses parce qu'il dise on a besoin
de plus de précisions pour que vous
motive y est le c de fermer les salles
et ça c'est un point important moi je
vais aussi mettre l'accent là dessus
c'est que heureusement on est dans un
pays où l'état le gouvernement
il fait pas tout ce qu'il veut comme il
veut mais il ya une justice qui contrôle
et qui peut poser des questions et
demandé de préciser les gabriel attal
moi moi sur votre sur votre explication
excusez moi sur la différence entre
l'école et les salles de sport je trouve
que à l'école minori énormément il ya
beaucoup plus de monde que dans une
salle de sport pour qu'il ya quand même
des interclasses où les élèves se
retrouvent et où ils sont vraiment
ensemble et mêmes il ya l'aria la
récréation je pense qu ai je trouve
comme ça a priori il ya beaucoup plus de
risques dans une salle de classe ou dans
un lycée ou dans un collège ou dans une
école que sur dans une salle de sport ou
au pire des cas dans une salle de sport
même si elle est bondé j'ai rarement vu
des salles de sport où il y avait plus
dans une salle vraiment de musculation
de vidalia des enfants à personne ne
sait vraiment très attention je dis pas
que les salles de sport n'ont pas pris
leurs précautions qu'elle ne sont pas
organisés pour aller en sorte que les
gens soient pas trop collé etc mais le
fait est que dans celles dans les écoles
primaires
il ya une constante scientifiques depuis
le début de la crise et ça ça n'a pas
bougé il ya beaucoup de choses qui ont
bougé mais ça ça va bouger c'est que les
enfants et jeunes enfants
ils font aucune forme grave quasiment
c'est rarissime quand il ya d'autres
maladies et 2 qui se transmettent
quasiment pas le bienvenu à ces salles
pour ces salles 2 en quart temps parce
que qu'ils fassent pas de temps mais
grave ça cc c'est important et c'est
bien mais c'est surtout nous ce qu'on a
peur c'est de la contamination c'est à
dire qu'ils sont entrés soir avec leurs
parents leurs parents vont voir leurs
parents donc les grands parents vont
être aussi contaminé et peut-être des
personnes à risque des personnes
fragiles
donc c'est donc là on a vu que les
scientifiques je parle sous le contrôle
du médecin encore une fois la haute
autorité de santé toutes les sociétés de
la psychiatrie telenet 18 collèges et
les lycées sur les écoles primaires et
sur les collèges et des nez c'est la
différence avec la salle de sport c'est
qu'ils ont tous le masque et que on leur
demande de respecter les gestes barrière
se laver les mains à masquer ce que ça
suffit réellement parce que moi
aujourd'hui je vois quand comme ryad
quand je parle avec les gens sur
internet et que les plus jeunes
je parle avec eux en live puisque la
démo en live je discute avec eux il ya
des mecs de 15 16 17 18 20 ans ils me
disent oh [ __ ] moi dans ma classe
il ya deux mecs qu'on covidien com en
cours moi même j'ai une cousine j'ai un
cousin qui avait commise il ne refera
pas leur papa il affine en réanimation
est ce que c'est une source sûre à 100%
que les jeunes transmettent mans ça je
ne sais pas et puis on dit la nouvelle
génération
elle doit montrer l'exemple mais la
nouvelle génération si aujourd'hui elle
se permet des droits pourquoi parce
qu'en leur on leur a aussi donné ses
droits monsieur moi je suis désolé
aujourd'hui si je vais au cinéma si si
je rejoins des joints ce cd gens si si
on se serre tous ensemble c'est que on
ajustera aujourd'hui en vrai le détenu
finement c'est quoi c'est juste mettre
un masque et s'écarter un peu des gens
parce que nous annonce était que le
déconfinement allait se faire tout
doucement et que le réel déconfinement
elle espère en décembre aujourd'hui à
part mettre un masque
il ya quoi comme mesure réellement prise
hier absolument rien les stades de foot
il ya mille 5000 personnes dans les
stades aujourd'hui tout le monde se voit
à l'école tout le monde est serré donc
non il veut métro est ce qu'on n'est pas
allé trop vite
monsieur duceppe pulse est fatale
monsieur le confinement est pas d'être
ils adorent abba amin bonne question
damine je trouve qu'il a il a bien
expliqué les choses et il a exprimé le
ressenti beaucoup beaucoup de gens
voilà donc je pense que c'est une bonne
question est ce que c'est vrai que qu'on
le découvre finement parce que je rejoue
ce que dit aline c'est que les gens
quand ils étaient confiées ils ont eu un
comportement franchement exemplaires
voilà que ce soit les jeunes que soient
les plus âgés tout le monde a eu un
comportement exemplaire et il ya
beaucoup de gens qui sont dit est ce qu
on ne confirme pas trop vite et il était
prêt à rester confinés encore après il y
avait une raison il y avait une
situation économique qui faisait qu'il
fallait qu'on déconfit mais la question
d'amis mais elle est intéressante et il
ya beaucoup de gens qui se la pose
est-ce qu'on a pris les bonnes décisions
et est-ce qu'on a des confiné au bon
moment où est ce que on s'est dit ce
qu'il fallait pas faire en plusieurs
fois c'est à dire faire un recond film
en moins libres parce que là on a eu
l'impression est sûre cabine pensent
comme moi quand on a dit on est des cons
filet même si on disait oui mais faut
faire attention tout le monde s'est dit
ça y est c'est la fête à l'erreur
bien ses cartes on connaissait tous mais
voilà gabriella talent quand on a des
consignes et peut-être plus encore dans
les semaines qui ont suivi le
déconfinement officiel il y avait
quelques centaines de contamination par
jour aujourd'hui on est à 13000 parfois
à 16000 il y avait quasiment plus
d'entrer dans les réanimations parce
qu'elle est quasiment plus de formes
graves
donc moi je vais vous dire je suis
persuadé que si on avait maintenu un
confinement très vite la pression
s'arrêter mais pourquoi vous nous
laissez confiné alors que l'épidémie a
autant chuté et qu'aujourd'hui elle ne
reprend pas deuxième chose moi cet été
quand je faisais des déplacements quand
je voyais le ministre de la santé
olivier ferrand faire des déplacements
pour a expliqué qu'il fallait faire
attention qu'il fallait porter le masque
qu'il fallait garder la distance qu'il
fallait se laver les mains régulièrement
parce qu'évidemment il n'y a pas que le
masque et là je vous rejoins le match
n'est pas le totem d'immunité qui fait
que parce que vous portez le masque vous
n'avez pas de problème j'ai déjà vu des
gens porter un masque est serré la main
ça n'a aucun sens on portait un masque
et se faire la bise
non c'est un ensemble de deux mesures et
à l'époque cet été lisez plutôt mais de
quoi vous nous parler le virus on a vu
que il a quasiment disparu
certains disaient même à l'époque y
compris des médecins disaient mais le
virus il va disparaître avec l'été ce
qui va faire chaud il y aura plus de
vivre voilà et nous on a tenu bon et à
ce moment là on a plutôt été critiqué
parce qu on continuer à alerter et à
prendre des mesures maintenant moi je
regrette pas du tout je pense que
c'était la bonne décision personne vous
a reproché de personnes reproché de le
déconfinement ni d'être confiné le
problème que je dis c'est que on a des
consignes et trop vite
c'est à dire que on a ouvert les portes
à tout le monde moi quand je regarde à
l'étranger par exemple comme disent les
championnats de foot il ya encore
personnes dans le public dans les stades
en maintien en allemagne en espagne dans
le public ya personne n'y a qu'en france
où d'ailleurs on a annulé championnat de
foot au début pour passer à 5000
spectateurs dans le pub dans dans les
stades c'est incroyable s'est mise
maintenant dans les endroits où il
visitera que lui devait y avoir un match
du psg un match 2-2 lyon il y avait 5000
personnes comme dans quick j'étais
étonné je regardais avec mon père je me
disais donc on annule un championnat de
foot pour passer de rien à 5000 je
trouve que c'était brutal
personne ne vous reproche d'être confiné
en fait ce qu'on reproche c'est que ça a
été beaucoup trop rapide les restaurants
peut-être que je sais pas fallait
peut-être faire q tu as remporté au
début ne pas ouvrir direct ou les restos
d'un seul coup je sais pas moi je sais
pas si vous avez des regrets
ce que vous dites à minsk moi je pense
j'y serais ce que tout le monde tâtonne
on le voit dans tous les pays à tout le
monde tâtonne tout le monde c'est au
mieux un petit peu et grosso modo quand
même quand on regarde avec nos voisins
européens
on prend grosso modo les mêmes décisions
il ya la question effectif
des jauges pour les grands événements où
c'est vrai que en allemagne par exemple
je crois que c'est encore sans public
mais là on considère qu'on a mis un
protocole open garros s'est il fait une
personne dans le lot il semble de la
personne qu'ils rendent tout par des
endroits différents à des moments
différents qui portent toutes un masque
et qui restent à distance dans l'est
dans les deux cas les grosses au modo la
grande bretagne ils viennent de fermer
leur barre à partir de 22h les pays bas
aussi on prend grosso modo les mêmes
mesures le coc vide il s'arrête à 22h ça
paraît j'entends halak alors ça c'est
une question qui a été énormément et je
regarde juste aux mines va revenir cette
question mais amine ce qu'ils disaient
et j'ai pas si si si si tu es d'accord
avec moi minh tu dis peut-être est-ce
que vous n'avez pas subi un peu trop de
pression vous avez il ne rien céder à la
pression des malades et des
restaurateurs qui eux qui ont raison
parce qu'il y avait besoin de manger ils
avaient besoin
il avait besoin fin de minerai de fer
entre un petit peu de change en fait là
la pression même des gros événement
sportif peut-être dévoila de la ligue de
football qui s'est dit fou pour quoi il
faut qu'on ait des téléspectateurs est
ce que vous avez eu une grosse pression
de différents lobbying comme ça assez
puissant ou es ce que vous avez pris la
décision vraiment seul son avoir été
forcé de prendre des décisions pour
faire plaisir aux uns et aux autres
moi je le dis depuis tout à l'heure la
seule chose qui a guidé le président le
premier ministre et qui continuent à
nous guider c'est la protection des
français on cède à aucune pression si on
considère aussi ont cédé aux pressions
ne sera pas en train de prendre les
décisions qu'on est en train de prendre
aujourd'hui qui sont difficiles et
ensuite parce que je voulais dire c'est
que dans votre intervention
j'ai eu l'impression que finalement
quand on a des consignes et on avait
tout d'un coup réouvert toutes les
vannes et on avait dit bah en fait on
peut tous se remettre à vivre comme on
vivait avant mais c'est ce qu'on ait
ressenti dans l'eau et non c'est pas ce
qui s'est passé dire tout ce dont on
parle depuis tout à l'heure le port du
masque la distance tout ce qui est
demandé aujourd'hui un nom mais dans les
restaurants que les régates war tout de
suite ça ça a été comme une erreur qui
n'a pas été obligatoire face oui c'est
vrai ce que vous dites
aucun pays qui a trouvé la solution et
comme tous les pays asiatiques y'a pas
de résurgence en asie alors y'a pas de
résurgence alors je ne sais pas vraiment
ça ici en corée du sud au japon et en
corée du sud au vietnam comme en ce
moment là les bons chiffres et au
vietnam c'est vrai qu'ils s'en sortent
très bien ça
oui c'est ce que miro ce qu'on disait
avec agathe et karine la semaine
dernière dans l'émission mais corée du
sud chine c'est c'est un peu plus
complexe
j'ai pensé c'est vrai spécialiste mais
je crois qu'il ya un exemple de pays
asiatiques qui a vraiment l'habitude
quand il ya des épidémies de tout de
suite mettre le masque de fer les tests
bref de tout faire comme il faut qui a
vu une deuxième vague arriver sans qu'on
puisse vraiment l'expliquer c'est le
japon ouais je crois qu'au japon il ya
une nouvelle vague alors même qu'ils
sourient d'exploit discipline et depuis
plus rien à voir avec ce qu'on a et en
europe
la leaf à choisir le virus s'est remis à
circuler les actions on a vu par exemple
si on en parlait la semaine d'ailleurs
on a vu qu'en suède
eux ils ont choisi l'immunité voilà ils
sont dit voilà on va essayer voilà de
faire sortir tout le monde et voir si on
arrive à 60 % de cas qui est un petit
peu le seuil pour qu'on se dise voilà la
l'épidémie va retomber
en ce sens les revenus de support et
tient ce qu'ils ont sur qui avait pour
sûr j'en ai rêvé dans les hôpitaux ils
sont venus dessus après la question
romande aminés et était intéressante et
c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui
disent pourquoi
à 22 heures le virus sera moins
dangereux qu'à 21h face aura plus
dangereux qu'à 21h c'est vrai qu'à cette
question il ya plein de gens qui on va
aller là dessus c'est à dire qu à 21h59
en naîtront tout c'est bon et à 22h01 ou
là tout le monde à la maison là il est
évident il est vener fait une after à la
maison tu fais une acteur avec tous tes
copains tu parais du bar et donc tu
serais venu quand même donc j'irai
tallieu pardon en fait la logique de
fermer à 22h c'est parce que les gens
après deviennent alcoolisées donc ils
vont pas forcément respecter les gestes
barrière chante pas porter le masque
pour vous c'est pour ça que c'est plus
dangereux à 22h donc c'est pour ça qu'il
ya la fermeture et moi mais c'est
quelque chose de l'algérie qu'au début
vous rigolez mais on a faim on a tous
ici était dans des bars on voit très
bien que entre l'happy hour
on a sa bière à 19 20h 21h et la fin de
soirée à minuit où tout le monde a un
coup dans le nez c'est pas la même chose
dans le bar qui sont dans des lieux où
on est susceptible d'être à colisée
alcoolisées ou pas ils sont dans le but
d'être perdu contact vois pas faire du
cinéma longtemps non plus s'ils sont
dans des bars et pas pour s'écarter des
gens bourrés ou pas je pense très
franchement je cause également quelque
chose enfin honnêtement je pense que
quand on est en début de soirée on boit
un coup on n'a pas encore beaucoup plus
et qu'on a encore en tête qu'il faut
rester responsable on peut se tenir un
peu à distance c'est sûr qu'on ne porte
pas son masque tout le temps par
définition parce qu'il faut boire mais
on peut se tenir un peu à distance et
qu'à partir d'une certaine heure on le
sait c'est toujours dur de trouver leur
bascule évidemment que les choses
changent pas radicalement entre 21h59 et
22h01 c'est évident il faut choisir une
heure et je donnais les exemples tout à
l'heure la grande-bretagne les pays-bas
et d'ailleurs beaucoup d'autres pays ont
choisi cette heure l'oeil mais monsieur
cette heure là elle est parue dans les
bars à lait pour les restos met d'accord
elle est pour les barbus aller pour les
bars et les restos oui le reste les yeux
fermés ou ferme complètement non les
restaurants si vous êtes encore à faire
vous pouvez rester à votre table après
ac ça après vingt deux heures à minuit
jusqu'à miner est guéri et du coup les
barres ces 22 heures c'est juste au cas
où on est alcoolisé du coup on peut
transmettre plus rapidement c'est à dire
que vous dites qu'en gros les gens qui
ne sont pas en gros les gens sont
alcoolisés après 22 heures mais pas
avant encore une fois je disais que sur
l'horaire évidemment c'est toujours dur
de trouver un horaire ce que je dis
c'est que le fut on le sait à partir
d'un moment dans la soirée plutôt en fin
de soirée quand tout le monde avait
moins vigilants c'est ça que les gens
sont moins vigilants forcément moins
responsables et donc il faut empêcher
c'est celle là et ces moments là moi il
m'arrive de rentrer du travail le soir
vers 22h 23h parfois mieux placés devant
débat jeu on voit on les voit tous ses
sens que les gens sont tous regroupés
nas et où évidemment ils n'ont pas leur
masse parce qu'ils sont en train de
boire et le fait est qu'en début de
soirée à vous avez je pense encore un
peu de 2,2 d'esprit faut pas non plus
imaginer que les gens sont totalement à
plat en fin de soirée mais pouvait
encore être responsable et être vigilant
il ya deux il ya deux sujets qui
reviennent oeuvres sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est les deux problèmes il y
ils n'ont pas été convaincus je vous le
dit gabriela talent par votre réponse
sur les collèges et les lycées
voilà où beaucoup de gens disent bas
collège lycée on est désolé on est les
uns sur les autres et puis derrière on
peut contaminer nos parents puis nos
grands parents etc
et il ya un deuxième sujet qui revient
énormément c'est les transports où les
gens sont les uns sur les autres et on
se dit ah pourquoi dans les transports
si on ferme les restaurants si on ferme
les bas comme à marseille par exemple
les transports en commun ils sont
toujours voilà en fonction et c'est vrai
qu'il ya des gens qui disent on est bon
voilà on est les uns sur les autres dans
les transports qu'est ce que vous
répondez à ça on aura du stress est une
chose d'abord c'est vrai qu'il ya des
lignes de transport et des horaires où
les gens sont les uns sur les autres
mais c'est pas possible ça ce n'est pas
acceptable
donc ça donc ça puisque et comme on le
dit c'est l'émission on est à 22 il est
22 heures 13 on est vraiment en direct
c'est les missions d'urgence aujourd'hui
ce soir parce que on se dit tous on a
quinze jours peut-être pour inverser la
tendance et éviter un rang confinement
donc qu'est ce qu'on fait avec ses
horaires l'échelon des qu'est ce qu'on
doit faire malgré les choses d'abord
font quoi demain les gens demain matin
on a travaillé que les opérateurs pour
qu'ils aient plus de trains ça permettra
de régler tous les problèmes
et deuxièmement on incite t on
recommande notamment dans les endroits
et les métropoles où le virus circule
beaucoup au télétravail pour que les
gens quand c'est possible
il travaille depuis chez eux pour éviter
de prendre les transports à la même
heure que tout le monde pour faire
baisser la pression sur les transports
donc ceux qui peuvent être en
télétravail
les patrons qui peuvent mettre leur
victoire hier les sétois c'est pas
possible pour tout le monde parce que
possible pour une partie des salariés en
tout cas et ensuite je reviens on vient
toujours là dessus dans les transports
vous avez votre masque quand vous portez
votre masque mais je dois nicolet ya pas
vraiment de doutes sur sujet en fait
comme si c'était une discussion mais on
sait très bien que les contaminations à
ce fonds dans les soirées dans les bars
et ans et qui a pas de contamination
dans les collèges les lycées les
transports ce qu'on avance on assassine
et ça s'est avéré vain le ministre vers
ans il a pas fait ces choses là comme ça
parce qu'il s'est dit dans les bars ont
fait la fed 22h à la il n'a pas fait les
choses comme ça y est après six ans que
j'ai débordé la tuer et à autre chose
qu'il faut bien comprendre sur cette
épidémie ce qu'en fait la plupart des
gens contamine personnes 90 % des gens
vous nous transmettez le virus à
personne mais à dix pour cent des gens
qui contamine tout le monde d'accord
comme ça que ça se passe
en fait quelques soirées sa relance
l'épidémie donc c'est pas chacun va
faire ses petites contamination dans son
entourage
ces quelques personnes qui vont relancer
l' épidémie en corée il ya un seul mec
cas relancer l'épidémie dans séoul parce
qu'il a fait dit bart et la contaminer
des centaines de personnes c'est ça les
comportements c'est à dire qu'en fait
c'est un virus de la fête mais des
grosses fêtes c'est pas un virus du
métro c'est pas un virus c'est pourtant
ce que vous niez voilà c'est ça c'est
pour ça que si jamais on est vite ça
doit pouvoir vivre quasi normalement et
au collège et au lycée ya pas de poster
je dire y'a pas eu des explosions de
d'épidémie ou les collégiens vont dans
des bars le soir cela foutrais sera pas
par les collégiens ça passe par les gens
qui d'après moi des collégiens et des
lycéens
1 viennent me voir et me dit et me dise
clairement des fois il ya des classes
avec deux élèves a neigé panier qui
avait aucun collégiens qui j'ai dit que
les gens qui transmettent les mines et
on le sait ça à partir de 18 jusqu'à 28
ans et à partir du moment où les gens
aiment il ya des lycéens qui sont les
arrête de tunisair qui sont contaminés
ou les lycées un d'occasion qui vont en
fête le samedi soir et qui règle le
lundi qui sont peut-être contaminés oui
mais ils vont oui mais la transmission
le dire c'est vrai dans les soirées
la transmission se fait non mais là déjà
c'est à dire que si vous voulez
transmettre il faut aller dans les
soirées où rossi ne donnait pas dans les
soirées en écrivant l'histoire a rappelé
le virus donc les soirées c'est le fléau
bien sûr l'un des campus docteur il ya
des étudiants en ce moment il ya même
des des campus qui essayent de terre les
clusters qui sont nés sans dans leur
université
vous êtes en train de nous dire que les
étudiants en ce moment que sont en train
de se transmettre le virus
ils risquent rien ça se transmet en
effet elle a dit que j'avais occulte
rhin mission j'ai dit que la plupart des
transmissions passer par les soirées
pourquoi en espagne si on explique
qu'une explosion épidémique ce parce
qu'ils ont fait la fête à barcelone dans
les bars sur la costa brava
c'est tour on le sait et appartenons
nous arrêtent et d'ouvrir les bars de
nuit et les boîtes de nuit ils ont
commencé dans le métro la dans la ligne
13 quand on voit les gens en train de
tenir les bars de métro etc
dans les études il ya aucune quand elles
sont dans les cinq vols dans le métro
mais c'est pas là que ça parce que vous
soyez dans un endroit clos que vous
parliez fort que vous chantiez vous
soyez avec tout le monde sait ça
l'ambiance de la transmission du virus
c'est pas vous passer un quart d'heure
dans un métro où vous êtes masqué c'est
pas comme ça que ça se passe
moi je vous donne ce qu'on se concerte
gabriel attaques qui visent à 20 le le
conseil c'est ce qui vous a dit de
conseils des médecins mais bien sûr je
pense est important qu'il soit là qu'ils
le disent parce que forcément quand
c'est le gouvernement ça c'est lui
l'audient c'est toujours suspect
maintenant quand les politiques il fait
pas partie du tout d'une grande
non pas du tout il va d'ailleurs ce que
vous avez
j'étais très critique moi j'ai remarqué
que le masque en extérieur ce n'était
pas utile j'ai pensé que le tester tracé
isolée c'était une bêtise j'ai toujours
dit qu'on aurait dû porter le masque
avant et que ans n'a pas été du site
cela j'étais extrêmement critique mais
en revanche fermeture des bars et des
restaurants pour contrôler l'épidémie je
suis désolé mais c'est la seule chose
qui va marcher et fermé les collèges et
les lycées ça va empêcher les élèves
d'aller au collège et au lycée et ça
servira à rien donc je préfère course il
ya un recond finement les collèges et
les lycées seront fermés
1re confiant a vécu le confinement au
printemps et tout était fermé
oui si un groupe est financé par
confinement de ceux de cette ampleur
comme j'ai dit tout à l'heure parce que
c'était vrai qu on n'envisageait pas
leur confinement aujourd'hui je peux pas
vous dire comment ça se ferait puisque
c'est pas sur la table
c'est vrai après encore une fois les
choses doivent se faire graduellement
peut-être qu'on aura à fermer d'autres
établissements plus tard je vous
apprends rien exclure ça va installer
l'application stop kobe michelin
installé la vierge 1 victoire mais c'est
bien j'invite les champs elle tire de la
semaine dernière comme on a vu que le
premier ministre les pinces territoire
oui mais le lendemain à mon avis tout le
monde s'est dit bon il faut l'installer
là le soir même là il ya eu un boum ça
ils ont tous installés devant moi
vous l'avez l'application se dopent
coville oui 6 non personne là vous savez
ce que c'est au moins maintenant je n'ai
jamais entendu parler de la pile jamais
entendu parler alors gabriela talent
parce que ça c'est important aussi bas
c'est important de le dire stop go vide
c'est une application qui a été
développé par la france qui permet sur
votre téléphone
d'enregistrer les autres téléphones avec
lesquels vous êtes restés en contact
un certain temps donc c'est plus de 15
minutes via le bluetooth
si jamais une des personnes que vous
avez croisé est testée positive au co
vide
elle va scanner son test sur
l'application et vous allez recevoir
parce que vous l'avez croisé une alerte
qui vous dit attention vous êtes reste
évidemment un certain temps à côté d'une
personne qui a été testée positive au
collier de mais c'est donc vous allez
allez faire un test et vous allez
pouvoir vous isolez il ya beaucoup de
pays en europe qui ont développé des
applications
la plupart ont fait le choix de le faire
avec google amazon facebook
enfin les géants du numérique nous on a
fait le choix de faire une application
française parce qu'on tient aux données
des français et qu'on veut pas que je
connais des français elles soient captés
par les géants du web
et c'est vrai que pour l'instant je le
dis l'application elle a pas trouvé son
public c'est à dire que
n'a pas suffisamment téléchargement on
absorbe faut le dire on est à 3 millions
de téléchargements non mais faut dire
les jeux ministre on est là pour se dire
les choses c'est pas il ya eu un peu
téléchargement c'est un flop tant il ya
3 millions de téléchargements s'est
passé quand on regarde en grande
bretagne maintenant quelques jours en
grande-bretagne ils vont lancer la leur
il ya quelques jours ils sont déjà à 14
millions peut faire beaucoup mieux à
parler anglais mais en tout cas j'ai
envie de le faire vous allez sur l'app
store vous allez taper ce top cow vide
et vous téléchargez l'application vous
l'activez et vous êtes obligés de
l'activer si vraiment vous voulez pas
d'activer tout le temps vous l'activez
au moins quand vous allez dans un
endroit où vous savez que vous allez
croiser du monde alors il ya quelqu'un
qui à 18 ans qui s'appelle mathieu qui
est président de l'union nationale
lycéenne qui est dans le public il est
où ma tu mates et léo mathieu merci
d'être là a levé vous mathieu basques
ont parlé la situation sanitaire sur les
lycées il ya un instant va en parler les
lycées et c'est vrai qu'il ya plein de
gens je vous dirais gabriel sur les
lycées et les collèges là c'est vrai que
l'explication elle a du mal à passer
même si le docteur a dit que c'était
c'était voilà c'était pas les lélés les
principaux voilà sans trop de mal à 2 de
contamination il ya beaucoup de gens qui
disent que ils sont étonnés par un papa
recettes répond alors mathieu vous
qu'est ce que vous avez à dire au porte
parole du gouvernement ce soit à notre
secrétaire d'état abou moussa a du mal à
passer l'explication qu'il n'y a pas de
conte à virus dans les lycées il ya des
classes qui toutes les semaines ferme
parce qu'on a des cas de coronavirus
dans les lycées voilà on a des
déclarations pas pu ouvrir à la rentrée
parce que les protocoles sanitaires
pouvait pas être appliquée et en fait on
comprends pas comment on peut nous dire
que je vais encore les soirées c'est
important de ne pas en faire et de décès
restent rares mais aussi comment on peut
nous dire à côté mais en fait c'est
normal d'aller à la fac dans des amphis
on nous fait ça on est les uns sur les
autres et d'aller dans des classes
surchargées où on et 38 c'est pas
possible
et en fait ça y'a rien qui a été fait
contre ça parce que entre l'année
dernière et cette année il ya 1800
postes de profs qui ont été supprimés
savait que mathématiquement une
déclaration plus nombreuses
ça fait qu'on ait plus nombreux dans les
classes et barbade ça fait qu'on se
prend ce qu'on se transmet plus le virus
et ça ça a pas que des conséquences
sanitaires ça c'est des conséquences sur
notre qualité d'éducation parce qu'après
les élèves qui ont déjà décroché pendant
le confinement parce qu'ils n'avaient
pas de cours mais en fait ils se
retrouvent dans des classes puis sont
bondées où il n'ya pas de suivi
personnalisé des élèves
et oui après mais en fait ils décrochent
et ça c'est grave surprendre l'éducatif
et ce grâce le plan social parce que
quand on décroche c'est pas seulement
nos études qu'on rate c'est aussi notre
vie en fait social qui est impactée et
sur l'action je continuais sur la
question des masques dire que tout le
monde à masquer oui tout le monde l'a
masquée mais en fait il ya des gens
qu'on paye moins de se payer des masques
parce que les mac ça coûte encore cher
j'ai des gens qui portent le même masque
depuis quatre jours et ça c'est pas
normal
les masses que là bas ça coûte aussi
cher on n'a pas les moyens on fait
actuellement nous on déjeune pas moi
j'ai eu 2 30 euros d'argent de poche par
mois concrètement c'est un peu compliqué
pour moi de m'acheter des masses mais
parce que ça allait moins non plus c'est
super comporte comprendre et je compense
vie parce que tirer que les masques on
us et ses cantons hamas mais au bout
d'un mois
c'est pour vous dire que ça quand tu
vois là et quand il parlait de 30 euros
par mois
ben si vous devez acheter un masque et
va prendre hamas tous les jours un
moment il va la lune on va le sentir
passer ça va être sayid adam il peut
être envie d'acheter autre chose que des
masques mine de rien c'est un budget les
masses quant à elle bien sûr c'est un
budget qui était qui était pas prévu
pour vous dans vos dépenses et c'est
vrai que ça c est ce qu est ce qu il ya
pas moyen peut-être aussi de mettre des
masques gratuits à disposition dans les
lycées dans les collèges mais on est là
on met à disposition des masses gratuit
on a envoyé 50 millions de masques
lavables et réutilisables à 8 millions
de familles pauvres de familles modestes
dans notre pays on a livré 50 millions
de masques supplémentaires en plus à des
associations qui interviennent auprès de
familles précaires de public précaire en
tout ça fait 100 millions de masques qui
ont été distribués gratuitement par
l'état à des familles je vous mets au
défi de trouver des pays qui en ont
distribué autant gratuitement à leurs
populations
deuxième chose on va continuer à en
envoyer par la poste à ces familles on
va continuer à en redistribuer tant que
le masque sera obligatoire parce
qu'effectivement tout le monde peut pas
se payer un masque voilà il ya des gens
qui peuvent se payer un masque et des
gens qui peuvent pas se payer un masque
qui ont pas les moyens
et nous on considère que la
responsabilité de l'état c'est
d'accompagner et d'aider ceux qui n'ont
pas les moyens de se payer de se payer
un masque et dans les établissements
scolaires on a mis en place des petits
stocks auprès des directeurs
d'établissement pour que si jamais il ya
un élève qui se présente qui seraient
passés entre guillemets entre les
mailles du filet qui aurait pas reçu les
masses gratuit qu'on a envoyé qui serait
pas en lien avec une association qui
distribue des bases gratuit ben puisse
lui remettre un masque pour qu'il puisse
porter un masque à l'école merci à daisy
mathieu mais pas en fait je pense qu'il
réponde de pédagogie autour de ça parce
que
à nous on a eu un cadre une élève s'est
fait refuser d'accès en place parce
qu'en fait elle n'avait pas de masque ça
c'est pas normal c'est pas normal bassin
d'accord c'est pas normal dira si elle
n'avait pas de masque et que
l'établissement lui a pas proposé un
masque pour aller dans le c'est pas
normal parce que là on a un stock pour
ça après il faut que n'aurait pas moi si
j'ai une question là c'est en fait on a
deux possibilités soit on va à l'école
et ben pâton n'est 38 par classe n'a pas
dessus personnalisé et on décroche ou se
renferme les écoles mais nous c'est pas
parce qu'on veut parce qu'en fait elles
vivront aussi décroché dans ce cas là
donc clairement comment on fait pour
faire en sorte que les élèves
il peut être accompagné individuellement
et qu'on puisse aller à l'école dans de
bonnes conditions sanitaires et aussi
dans des coins qui nous permettent de
nous sentir bien placé une question qui
revient souvent gabriela talent vous
voyez le médecin qui voulait à répondre
aussi bien mais je comprends pas bien en
fait parce que je comprends pas ce que
je voulais je suis désolé parce que vous
voulez changer cet actif sur les lycées
parce que nous on voit des gens qui
chantent coronado dans le temps mais le
coronavirus y circulent partout donc
comme les gens qui vont au lycée sont si
des gens qui vivent dans la vie de tous
les jours et qui est comprise bon
souvent dans des soirées il va y aller a
requis en cours aux navires us moi je
dis pas qu'il y ait aucun lycéen que
d'être lycéens vous vaccine contre le
corner rue c'est parce que j'ai dit ce
serait bien mais c'est pas ce qui arrive
je dis que c'est pas les lycées qui sont
des endroits propagateur du virus voilà
moi je resterai un lycéen barque armand
n'est toujours pas les lycéens barbate
un super lycée alors parce qu on est
autant un problème vous portez un masque
dans un bar vous je comprends ce que tu
dis il ya beaucoup de l'eau sur les
réseaux sociaux qui sont assez d'accord
avec mathieu si on ne voit pas la pole
je vois pas la différence entre un lycée
et un ba1
c'est ce qu'on disait il ya un instant
série classe sur cette explication
docteur même si vous nous avez donné des
chiffres il ya beaucoup de gens qui
disent j'ai l'impression que je peux
plus attraper
lakovic 19 dans mon lycée ou dans vos
collège que quand je vais boire un verre
il y aura jamais autant de monde dans un
bar que dans leur lycée ou au collège
comme nous a dit matthew lynn surtout
dans ces bars et des adultes ils sont
korea mine ils sont quand même plus tard
à suivre des règles dans des écoles
responsables sont leurs que c'est là où
il faut mettre des règles beaucoup plus
strictes c'est moins dans les barques
dans les écoles je pense alors karim
zéribi avant de vous poser quelques
questions à notre secrétaire d'état qui
nous fait le plaisir d'être là ce soir
moi j'ai une pensée quand même ce soir
monsieur le ministre je pense que vous
l'avez aussi pour le personnel
hospitalier
pour toutes ces aides soignantes et 6e
firme hier et ses docteurs et même ses
personnels et j'ai envie de dire qu'ils
entretiennent donc les hôpitaux parce
que ils sont sur le sur le feu depuis le
mois de février mars dernier qu'il ya
une petite accalmie cet été mais là ça
repart puisqu'on a des hospitalisations
nouveau qui repartent et donc c'est un
personnel qui souvent eu le sentiment de
ne pas être considéré comme il se devait
donc j'espère que dans la durée le
gouvernement prendra en compte leurs
conditions de travail surtout leur
rémunération
ce que celle ci se doit d'être vraiment
revaloriser ce soir qu'est ce qu'on
entend on n'entend pas que le
gouvernement ne se soucie pas de la
situation
on est tout à fait conscient je crois
les uns des autres même ceux qui portent
des critiques de que que la situation
est complexe
c'est une crise planétaire il n'y a pas
un pays qui donne l exemple de qui a su
s'en sortir
merveilleusement bien que tout le monde
a eu jamais de dire ces
dysfonctionnements et ses aspects
positifs
néanmoins il ya deux trois choses qui
ressorte monsieur le ministre et
j'aimerais bien que vous peut-être
répugné à ces interrogations l'a d'abord
il ya le souci de la cohérence chez nos
concitoyens et le gouvernement sur la
question et la questure et sanitaire n'a
pas toujours donné le sentiment d'être
cohérent on est passé de le masquer sa
sert a rien au masque pour tous et
partout
la tension est vrai que masquer
maintenant c'est la semaine soit bien
appris ce grand écart ça a été un
marketeur le mazet dit tout à l'heure un
peu d'égalés change et puis on n'a pas
compris ce grand écart pour tous et
partout
quand on est seul dans la rue on se dit
le masaï mais non finalement ne peut
prendre une amende ne sera pas bon ça
c'est pas très cohérent
de canaliser ce parce que tout le monde
comprend qu'il faut le porter les
français sont prêts à respecter ce
qu'ils comprennent et pour ce faire je
pense que ce qu'il reproche aussi c'est
le climat anxiogène qui est créée autour
de la copie 19 mai on a l'impression
qu'ils avaient toujours dans le dans la
dramatisation
on essaie c c'est la fin du monde on
peut pas vivre dans ce contexte là et
c'est assez contradictoire de la posture
du président la république qui dit il
faut qu'on s'habitue à vivre avec
mais si on doit s'habituer à vivre avec
on ne peut pas vivre dans l'habitude je
dirais de l'anxiété
c'est pas viable et ceux qui ont partir
des pressions qui vont partir en stress
de qui va se poser des questions en
permanence comment faire pour
dédramatiser
alors que c'est quand même un peu ce que
vous donnez parfois le sentiment de
faire et le ministre de la santé et le
premier ministre le président - ce que
le président a répété encore ces jours
ci je l'écoutais du moment il faut
concilier l'économie et la santé indique
que c'est possible aux paysans il n'y
croit ça il dit la confiance l'état
d'esprit ne conseille pas combien de
temps ça va durer six mois un an deux
ans donc il faut qu'on s'habitue
mais il nous dit faut qu'on s'habitue
tout en vivant pas en refusant de vivre
or parfois il ya des mesures qui donnent
le sentiment que la vie s'arrête mais
c'est pas possible on ne peut pas
imaginer un visage et que la vie
s'arrête de que quand on vous dit on
ferme les salles de sport et des gens
qui comprennent pas il se dit déçu des
sports qui respecte à la distanciation
c'est pas comme sports d'eau sur mars où
on a des corps à corps c'est ce que l'
usine à fait c'est une enseigne
parisienne et c'était le café le recours
et de kaki a réussi là de carreaux
mettre en cause de l'arrêter parce que
c'est une salle de sport qui a pris les
mesures mais vous ne tenez pas compte
vous mettez salle de sport aux sports de
combat vous mettez tout de même paquet
ma restaurant pareil moi j'ai des amis
marseillais qui ont investi dans le
restaurant nominés plexiglas ils
respectent les distances sont dix
couverts ils en font que 50
il teste depuis des pistes leurs
salariés matelot masque vous les avez
traité comme ceux qui respectaient pas
le fm paquet cadeau offert le tout ils
sont pas compris ils ont dit qu est ce
que c'est moi déjà j'ai du mal
j'ai investi et derrière on me fait de
sa relation ça revient beaucoup comme
ceux qui ne respectent pas est-ce que
vous n'auriez pas dû en ce sens
renforcer le contrôle on a dix sept
mille contrôleurs de l'urssaf est ce
qu'on n'aurait pas dû leur mettre une
branche sanitaire pour que tous les
jours il a aidé les établis
ma il vérifie et même dans les salles de
sport pourquoi vous avez mis tout le
monde dans le même sac
comme si personne ne respecter les
règles alors que la france au mois de
mars
quant aux vieilles copines et tout le
monde l'a respecté le confinement tout
le monde est que les copines quand vous
dites le masque dans le métro tout le
monde le mais quand vous dites le masque
de qu'il faut le mettre dans les écoles
les gamins le respecte un moment donné
je pense que vous avez péché par manque
de cohérence de clarté de pédagogie de
que vous avez créé un climat anxiogène
et les français refusent de vivre dans
un climat anxiogène
quand eux notre médecin présent il dit
si le virus de la fête
je suis désolé mais c'est une expression
qui parle beaucoup plus que des grands
discours
quand vous initier le diffuseur a fait
moi je suis jeune je suis lycée où je
suis à la fac je me dis bon les gars
faut pas qu on déconne l'arrêté gens nos
potes donc peut-être il faut qu'on soit
un peu moins à nadal a fait mais ça ne
nous empêchera pas d'avoir des relations
sociales
là vous avez créé un climat qui n'est
pas claire qui n'est pas comment
dirais-je pédagogue et là encore une
fois je préférerais que vous mettiez à
une heure de grande écoute
un médecin qui dit les gamins si le
virus de la fait arrêter sinon vous
allez vous comptez faire passer avec eux
mais ce soir je pense que le message en
rien il est il est clair il est simple
avec des mots simples parfois le
politique qui complexifie les choses et
les rend compliqué de que il crée la
peur il crée la société
franchement monsieur le ministre vous
êtes jeunes peut-être que c'est à vous
aujourd'hui de prendre de la mine
donc dans les messages qui sont passés
au gouvernement avec des mots simples
avec des mots simples le miz la santé
qui est arrivé à marseille et qui a dit
dans 48 heures on ferme les bars les
restos comment voulez vous que ce soit
même prix encore une fois alors qu'il ya
des guerres qui respectait pas il
fallait la fermer l'établissement et
avaient été respectées ou les voleurs
avaient fermé de la même manière de
combiner cette république juste et
équitable et en l'occurrence ce soir
j'en entends qui le musée la santé avant
de devenir qu'est ce qui nous dit que la
situation à paris est aussi grave qu à
marseille
est-ce qu'il a pris la mesure de
fermeture des restaurants la réponse est
non
moi je m'en réjouis ils n'ont pas ce que
moi je suis paré jeune gardien
marseillais lundi
non il a dit il a dit nous prendrons
la décision lundi avec la mairesse de
paris dans les jours qui viennent en
fonction de la situation et il a précisé
que la profession lui faire des
propositions pour renforcer la
distanciation les gestes barrière donc
maintenant on écoute la profession et on
écoute la mairesse de paris à marseille
j'avais écouté ni le maire ni le
président de région ni le secteur
d'activité ça fait beaucoup
ça fait beaucoup donc si vous voulez que
les gens adhèrent il faut qu'ils
comprennent
il faut qu'ils partagent donc ils sont
pas inconscients les français ils ont
respecté et là où cyril a raison quand
on a dit on des consignes on a vécu ça
comme une forme de libération c'est ça
aussi d'y aller on va retrouver notre
aliciens de vie et non vous auriez dû à
un moment donné lâchez les choses petit
à petit par étapes pas là aussi avec
pédagogie de cure à marseille je suis
désolé quand vous dites que cet été vous
êtes venu à marseille on avait 42 % de
touristes dans la ville 40 % de
touristes qui ont été contaminés qui
sont repartis chez eux avec le virus
peut-être qu'on aurait dû à un moment
donné limiter les déplacements se
découpent finement ok on va revivre un
peu comme a marre on a retrouvé cette
terre qu'on a mis mais peut-être qu'on
va le faire de manière modérée voulait
pas fait de manière modérée
je suis désolé au début on a mis de
limites de déplacement à nîmes il sent
qu'il juillet ou août vient vous le
savez le soleil la valette la mer suivre
et vous pensez quoi que les gens vont se
réguler tout seul je pense que les gens
ils peuvent comprendre qu'il faille
poser des limites
mais il faut leur expliquer il faut les
rassurer et il faut le faire avec des
mots simples
or vous êtes passé à côté de ces
messages là je précise juste une chose à
votre avantage
les mesures économiques et sociales que
vous avez prises je crois qu'il ya pas
un seul pays au monde qui les a prises
autant je suis critique sur les
questions sanitaires sur la manière dont
vous n'avez pas toujours été cohérent
sur les messages contradictoires ou qui
était absente de pédagogie autant ça
questions économiques et sociales
chômage partiel prêts garantis par
l'état reports de charges
il ya très peu de pays qui l'ont fait
donc un coût ne font peut être critique
sur le gouvernement m'ont peut aussi
reconnaître que vous avez fait des
choses bien saisi beaucoup de choses il
a fait un petit peu votre bilan moi je
suis seule chose il ya trois mots il ya
trois moments à iasi marquer vous avez
dit vous péché par manque de cohérence
par
de clarté et manque de pédagogie et vous
créer de l'anxiété way sur la cohérence
et la clarté
moi je pense que cette crise elle rend
très difficile le fait d'être cohérent
est clair tout simplement parce que
depuis que ce virus est apparu
on découvre chaque jour chaque semaine
des nouvelles choses sur le terrain une
des premières choses que j'ai dit en
arrivant sur ce plateau
c'est justement que je n'ai pas de leçon
aux français sur les questions de
masques et des responsabilités parce
qu'il ya encore quelques semaines ou
quelques mois
il entendait des membres du gouvernement
sur la base de ce que disaient les
scientifiques de ce que disait
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
expliqué que le masque était pas utile
parce que à ce moment là la science elle
disait ça et le médecin et les pays
asiatiques ont fait mieux le contrôler
et d'épidémies depuis des décennies il
met thomas ils ont une tradition une
tradition les accès aux meilleurs jeunes
sont une tradition pour se faire plaisir
non la vérité monsieur lessard a empêché
n'avait pas de masse moi j'ai interrompu
personnes en moravie béni oui oui c'est
vrai j'ai interrompu personnes dans
l'offre saas est vrai qu on m a d'abord
ensuite voyait là tu as donc cohérence
difficile parce que les choses évoluent
cohérence difficile ensuite parce que
mon assume ne pas prendre les mêmes
mesures partout et c'est ça aussi
parfois qui brouillent le message
quand j'entends des gens parfois qui
m'écrivent qui me disent mais je
comprends pas pourquoi la vous fermez
tel truc alors chez mon copain qui
habite dans un autre département vous
fermez pas et ça aussi c'est parce qu'on
assume on veut que les règles et que les
restrictions elles soient considérées
comme justes et nécessaires par ceux qui
les subissent
entre guillemets voilà si on me restera
ma vie sociale c'est parce que près de
chez moi le virus il circule plus et je
comprends que les parents ont ils perdu
dix années répond pas ça s'arrange hyper
difficile d'être cohérent je vais
arriver
la suite et la pédagogie oui je suis
d'accord c'est pour ça que je suis là ce
soir peut-être pas une émission dans
laquelle un porte parole du gouvernement
est le plus attendu voilà mais je
remercie cyril hanouna de l'avoir
organisé parce que moi je suis là aussi
pour venir m'expliquer pour essayer
d'expliquer les choses pour j'essaye de
le faire de la manière la plus claire
possible je suis pas forcément toujours
très riches claires j'essaye mais
j'essaye de passer c'est saignant
voiture à une dernière chose que je
voulais dire c'est que à aucun moment la
jeter la pierre à personne
à aucun moment on a dit les
restaurateurs ont pris à marseille vous
ça a été fermé vous avez été totalement
et responsable vous avez rien fait et
ces personnes a tenu ce discours
au contraire on reconnaît qu'il ya une
grande responsabilité qu'un protocole
sanitaire qui a été mis en place qu'à la
distance qui a été fait qu'elles ont
rien fait la part des choses
jalloul a vibré maroco le port du masque
entre ceux qui respectent et ceux qui
respectaient pas monsieur michel le port
du masque qui est
du obligatoire quand vous traversez le
restaurant à partir d'un moment quand
vous avez une telle circulation du virus
dans une ville comme marseille que vous
avez un tel niveau de contamination des
personnes âgées que vous avez les
réanimations qui sont quasiment saturés
sa boîte à partir d'un moment vous
pourrez plus accueillir des malades
comme l'an dernier mais c'est ce qu'on
fait c'est bien le problème
vannes en effet le problème on a 300
lits au marseille deuxième ville de
france ce n'est pas le tien à minuit à
paris c'est pas le fait qu'ils aient ou
et je vais vous dire les lions du plus
ou moins à l'hôpital public c'est ce
qu'on fait qu'est ce qui s'est passé il
ya quelques semaines le ségur de la
santé on a débloqué plus de 10 milliards
d'euros pour l'hôpital public pour
revaloriser ce qui travaille à l'hôpital
pour que ce soit plus attractif pour que
les gens aient envie d'aller y
travailler pour créer des lits 4010 qui
vont être créés dans les prochains mois
merci ça se répare en deux secondes
c'est pas juste
on va monter un lit il faut une
infirmière derrière il faut voir un
médecin homme ou femme d'ailleurs
j'étais infirmière mais un infirmier une
infirmière ou un médecin
derrière tout ça se fait pas tout de
suite et autre chose que je veux dire
parce que ça c'est un point très
important je vois beaucoup je reçois
beaucoup de messages sur les réseaux
sociaux ou encore une fois de gens qui
me disent on voit bien que le problème
est le risque c'est que les opérer
animations des hôpitaux soient saturés
et c'est ça qui fait que voulait freiner
le virus oui pourquoi tout simplement
bah vous augmentez pas de jeu vous
devrez pas vous triplé pas les lits de
réanimation
comme ça on n'aura pas à prendre de
mesures de sanction pour aller passer
sur bonnes questions mais non d'abord on
met les moyens pour créer des lits mais
ça se fait pas en un claquement de
doigts et 2 peut pas réguler une
épidémie par le nombre de lits de
réanimation pour 10 personnes qui
rentrent en réanimation
en moyenne on avait trois timmer comment
est-ce qu'on peut accepter de dire on va
accueillir dix fois plus de gens
répondre à tous les médecins ont besoin
c'est que si on vous connaît pas le
nombre de lits monsieur le ministre
parce qu'il n'ya pas le personnel c'est
ça mais on fait tout pour avoir dû
personne n'aimerait pas le personnel
chez séduire la santé ses 15000 postes
concret entre humains ont finalement
c'est gabriel attal là je vais vous
poser une question vous allez avoir le
le ton de la pub pour pour y réfléchir
il ya beaucoup beaucoup de gens sur les
réseaux sociaux qui disait également
eelv on retrouve fini pourquoi pour
qu'on ne voit pas les carences au niveau
du personnel hospitalier
parce que si l'épidémie continue à
grimper
on va voir que dans les hôpitaux ils
sont débordés que le personnel
hospitalier est malheureusement
on sous-effectif et que la seule
solution de pouvoir dire voilà on ne pas
montrer ses carences c'est de repasser
en confinement je vous laisse réfléchir
à ces questions et deuxième question que
je vous pose est juste après parce que
j'ai vu tout le monde c'est sur la
communication
et c'est vrai que là tous les jeunes
autour qui sont là autour de la table
ils sont d'accord sur un truc c'est que
c'est extrêmement anxiogène et
qu'olivier verrons il fait certainement
très bien son travail
le ministre de la santé mais au niveau
de la communication
c'est quelqu'un qui est arrivé après
agnès buzyn et si ça lui est tombé
dessus comme ça il a pris la plus grosse
crise sanitaire jamais connues dans le
monde et il a pris en pleine face c'est
quelqu'un qui fait voilà que je n'ai
rien contre lui je connais pas du tout
mais qui est quand même extrêmement
anxiogène et en termes de communication
on peut pas dire c'est celui qui rassure
le plus
il faut qu'ils démontrent acte qui
explique les bleus qui soit le plus
pédagogique soit moi je vous dis qu'à
une intervention d'olive et veyran jeudi
8 façons il a une tête qui va nous
annoncer des mauvaises nouvelles c'est
et on comprend pas ce qu'il dit alors
oui j'aimerais joulie vous dis ce que je
vois sur les berceaux bon riz si on se
dit la vérité ce soir et c'est avec
olivier ferrand c'est pas le meilleur
communicant pour faire face à cette
crise je trouve personnellement
qu'aujourd'hui le premier ministre ou
emmanuel macron devrait plus s'exprimer
jeudi
jean cette crise est plus prendre la
parole parce que je trouve qu'en termes
de communication
ils sont plus rassurants coli les vers
en 1912 laisse réfléchir là dessus je
veux quand même réponse sur ce point la
belle sur la ligne répondre dans un
instant mais on se retrouve dans un
instant pour la deuxième partie balle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
kay et nude prochain by dolce and
gabbana gère français merci d'avoir
aller au sujet des sous toutes prêtes à
c'était pour saler on pourrait déjà vu
guy roux et merci d'avoir aller sur leur
composition 1 621 grâce à vous les
soupes liebig en changer descend
désormais cuisiner avec 100 %
d'ingrédients naturels pour des recettes
toujours plus savoureuse merci d'avoir
fait grandir vos sous liebig d'un 3,2 à
en est heureux quand on est ensemble et
pourtant plus grand bonheur le sac de
croquettes selecto gold complique maxi
adultes 12 kg baffes et à seulement 35
euros 99 maxizoo je peux vous proposer
du blanc du blanc léger cas c'est
brillant coup de rennes où un plan
sombre et vous vous n'auriez pas
quelques chose de plus original
voyons le monde avec un oeil nouveau
skoda gamiq la nouvelle référence des
suv urbain skoda est disponible dès
maintenant à partir de 199 euros par
mois hors prime à la conversion
[Musique]
une heure je l'écarté distribuer
accroche-toi on va jusqu'à la river et
même l'esprit affûté prends ta chance
52 cas de maux prime elle
[Musique]
zawawi
fillon
[Musique]
work 2000 nouveaux rana frais minutes
des pâtes fraîches et une sauce
onctueuse avec des ingrédients de
qualité à cuisiner en seulement cinq
minutes
non mais t'es sérieux là
chéri qu'elle tue faux bureaux râle
après minute
et vous quelle bonne excuse allez vous
en vanter d'être la fille de son amie
[Musique]
donnant une seconde vie à nos téléphones
déjà 15 millions étaient collectés
continue par ange emma le matelas pour
tous et du produit de l'année ni trop
ferme ni trop souple estello pendant son
ennui sans risque dormez mieux dans mes
heureux et m'a commandé leur ligne dès
maintenant mais magic
elles sont vraiment magiques polir
magique au soleil magique non
et quand je paie master 2 encore plus
magique je ne sais pas moi c'est apple
quelques secondes correction ce magic
avec deux clés poncho ses 149 euros
seulement dispositif médical
[Musique]
michelin parcourt le monde et déniche
pour vous les meilleures tables au
michelin
ça marche pas mal
[Musique]
little green ice-t commence avec de
véritables feuilles de thé vert pour un
goût délicieusement frais léger avec
lipton greenhalgh s'y ajouter une touche
de légèreté avaient trait journée dès
1996 on a supprimé les sacs plastique à
usage unique de nos caisses 20 ans
devant la loi et ça c'est un milliard de
sacs en moins aujourd'hui on va encore
plus loin
on remplace tous les sacs plastiques de
nos caisses par les 50 hall de jute
recyclables échangeables acquis et bim
7000 tonnes de plastique en moins
le nouveau geste pour les emplettes et
pour la planète leclerc lancé cinq en
toile de jute disponible dès maintenant
une pierre
[Musique]
découvrez les sensations de conduite
unique des nouvelles rondeurs jazz est
achevée hybride et parier sur l'avenir
avec la garantie moteur offerte jusqu'à
10 ans rendez-vous en concession pour
profiter des nouvelles jazz hybride à
partir de 17 1490 euros
[Musique]
pour la voiture électrique j'ai pas
encore tranché mais pour faire installer
ma borne de recharge et pas hésiter oui
c'est sûr tous ces travaux ici c'est
simple c'est easy à bout ça s'appelle et
goulet mais oui madame négligence un peu
plus tard on confond pas avec un autre
mot gt rien ce qu'on mange
l'herbe est en ce moment retrouver dans
le happy meal le macm finnegan cheese et
pour votre prochain mac do en famille
fait délivrer découvrez l'alliance
parfaite d'arômes incomparable
capturé dans chaque capsules l'or
espresso aluminium
[Musique]
pour un plaisir intense lors sans doute
le meilleur café du monde
[Musique]
votre programme avec la cifit game.fr
gaines amincissantes qui affine et
sculpte votre silhouette classifie
deviennent point fr votre programme avec
l'europe rodin retraite prévoyance
assurance vie gros pro d'un penser votre
épargne
[Applaudissements]
sur ces huit ses balances ton post est
juste après il y aura le débrief de
cette soirée avec eric naulleau et tous
les éditorialistes et nous sommes avec
le porte parole du gouvernement
secrétaire d'état auprès du premier
ministre gabriel attal merci d'être là
et merci de vous confronter aux jeunes
merci de vous confronter aux
téléspectateurs j'aimerais car qu'on
enchaîne aussi des questions sur twitter
vraiment n'hésitez pas on en a plein on
va en enchaîner quelques unes on va se
faire une petite rafale de questions
twitter dans un instant et il ya un
moment je vous ai posé une question et
c'est vrai que pendant la pause
j'en ai parlé avec zeus riyad avec voilà
etc avec pas mal de monde avec malek
également c'est vrai que on voulait
attendre votre réponse sur la
communication
mine de rien et est serré qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens je vous dis inscrire
tous les ressorts sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est on préfère quand c'est le
président qui parle que quand ces olives
et veyran le mini de la santé et à
l'industrie a dit m'a dit qu'est ce
qu'il m'a dit banny fait peur moi j'ai
dit frère qu'on aime la télé des fois on
comprend rien à ce qui se passe badiane
comprend un de ceux qui a raison il faut
le dire et moi maintenant quand il ya
des annonces comme ça oui lui il va
parler lui va parler à moi je me sens
pas concerné et du coup je regarde pas
ben moi je comprend près encore macro et
20 comme à quoi il parle j'ai
l'impression qu'ils récitent un poème
d'accord mais alors que olivier ferrand
il est médecin du coup quand il parle je
suis en mode
donc merci donc ça c'est vrai vous
comprenez je comprends mais il faut mais
pas une petite race rare une petite
angoisse email titre et sera mais c'est
vrai qu'on a eu on y pallier non parce
qu'on parlait de nos gènes donc sur
l'unité voilà de deux volets de cette
liste et que la communication est serré
qu'aux la lampe alors là c'est
l'émission où il ya des des jeunes voilà
qui qui qui sont aussi concernés comme
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure c'est le
virus de la fête donc c'est important de
faire passer des messages
et franchement qu'est ce que vous en
pensez vous de oliveira
oui non mais de la communication par
olivier derand de communication
l'éducation sur les coiffures sur le
général a quitté skate vous emboîter
stop quand vous savez qu'il ya une
allocution d'olivier vers un ca angoisse
dans le sens où ça rassure tu me fais
pas on sait pas que ça c'est que c'est
pas on sait pas où on va
en vrai moi je pense que les gens ils
aimeraient se prendre une au contraire
je pense que j aimerais faudrait plus
les est beaucoup plus strict avec eux
fowler faut leur faire beaucoup plus
peur pas situation et je pense aller
faire beaucoup plus tôt on revient sur
le déconfinement cac a pris beaucoup
trop de temps mais à l'heure actuelle il
ya des gens qui sont
c'est parce que donc tête choper la
maladie il ya des gens qui sont
angoissés parce qu'ils ont peut-être pas
ils vont peut-être fermer leur
entreprise actuellement il ya des gens
qui sont coincés police
ils savent pas ce qui va se passer les
prochaines semaines sont perdus malek
délégué juste on a parlé des masques
rapidement et ensuite je parle de
déconfinement vous aviez dit tout à
l'heure que le gouvernement avait changé
un petit peu de discours sur le sur les
masses parce que la science aussi avait
avancé malheureusement c'est parce que
nous on a vu moi j'ai vu des hôpitaux en
ile de france qui demandait bon ben si
vous avez des charlottes des blouses des
masques et on est preneur parce qu'on
n'a pas les masques étaient pas produit
chez nous en tout cas on petite partie
de quoi on a attendu sur nos petits amis
chinois et au final c'était le far west
en pleine crise sanitaire donc dire la
vérité là il ya quelques jours florence
parly a avoué qu'elle avait menti devant
devant les français à l'anglais npc
compétent mais en tout cas des armes
arrivant elle ne savait pas que c'est
tromper mais elle avoué je pense qu'il
faut aussi avouer quand on se trompe si
une crise sanitaire
y'a pas que je pense pas qu'ils aient de
bonnes décisions il ya des mauvaises
décisions à prendre
mais il faut aussi être nette face aux
français donc sur les masques dira
peut-être bon bah oui on a dit qu'il
fallait pas les porter juste parce qu'on
en avait pas et aujourd'hui voilà on en
a donc porté les premières choses sur le
déconfinement orienté je pense pas qu'on
ait loupé le déconfinement par contre je
pense que depuis bientôt talent flou sur
la stratégie
on le voit bien notre génération ne le
comprends pas notre génération a été
exemplaire vous l'avais dit au début
pendant confinement mais pourquoi parce
qu'on avait une visibilité dans l'espoir
on nous a dit il faut être confiné c'est
ce qui va freiner le virus ensuite on a
eu cette date le onze mecs qui nous a
permis aussi de savoir bon ben voilà on
a on a vu une vision sur sur le court
moyen terme
là aujourd'hui on patauge moi je je je
ne sais pas ce qui va se passer dans
deux trois semaines plan a plan b si
l'épidémie repas repas repas etc et on
ne comprend pas on avait la messe
edouard philippe à l'époque olivier vers
ans et c'était plus ou moins clair on
avait le président de la république qui
venait à 20h pour nous parler et là
olivier ferrand qui vient nous parler à
18h alors par qui c'est qui qui et qui à
ce sujet la messe de 18 heures je sais
pas et qui a vraiment compris
je sens encore moins donc sur la
communication du gouvernement
aujourd'hui venir ici sur ce plateau
c'est une première action et merci
monsieur le ministre mais pour la suite
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire aujourd'hui
pour ce soit plus clair pour les
français pour les jeunes notamment
on fait au mieux moi je veux d'abord
répondre sur l'idée verrons mais olivier
verrons ça
10 les médecins surtout il est ministre
de la santé donc son boulot parce qu'on
a fait ce choix là depuis le début
c'est de faire la transparence c'est de
dire exactement ce qui se passe dans le
pays et donc oui c'est sûr qu'en ce
moment c'est pas des bonnes nouvelles et
on espère qu'à un moment ça sera des
meilleures nouvelles d'un bus moment-là
moment on a pu organiser le
déconfinement donc il fait son travail
je peux dire je le connais très bien ils
rêvent que d'une chose c'est de pouvoir
donner des messages et des positive les
messages positifs aux français ils
aiment faire la fête il avoue retrouver
ses amis c'est un jeune papa il est élu
dans un territoire
je peux vous dire il n'est pas c'est pas
il prend pas du plaisir à donner dès
lors est assez important des rues ou sur
les réseaux là c'est bien c'est son
boulot son boulot de liste de la santé
parce que c'est ce que lui demande le
président et premier ministre d'être
transparent parce que quand on n'est pas
transparent et que on ne dit pas les
choses tout de suite on nous accuse de
vouloir vendre du rêve et de cacher les
choses donc nous on fait la transparence
c'est vrai que parfois on se prend ça en
pleine face on se prend des mauvaises
nouvelles on n'a juste pas envie d'avoir
cette perspective la deuxième chose que
vous avez dit sur le fait le côté on n'a
pas de cap
mais personne n'a de personne ne sait où
on en sera dans quelques mois dans cette
épidémie aucun pays dans le monde
aucun scientifique il y en a qui ont
essayé un courrier en a qui ont essayé
au printemps de nous dire c'est fini et
même des scientifiques très connus dont
on a beaucoup parlé qui ont essayé de
nous dire le virus il a cette arme
pendant l'été ou la voilà il y en a qui
ont fait des paris et des plans sur la
comète
ils se sont pas produits donc on est
quand même très prudent sur ce point là
moi ce que je dis ce que vous avez
raison je pense que les jeunes ils sont
prêts à se mobiliser et ils veulent du
sens à savoir pourquoi ils se mobilisent
et moi le message que j'ai voulu passer
ce soir le message je crois que vous
passez avec protège des potes oui c'est
le fait que tout le monde on peut être
acteur de la protection des français et
qu'un jeune ton copain votre copain qui
va pas organiser son anniversaire samedi
comme l'avait prévu le derrière de 70
personnes et bâle aurait peut-être qu'un
directement ou indirectement parce qu'il
va pas organiser cet anniversaire parce
que peut-être que du coup des
contaminations qui aurait dû avoir lieu
vont pas avoir lieu peut-être que des
personnes qui auraient été contaminés
aurait contaminé des personnes âgées en
organisant pas son anniversaire il a
peut-être sauvé des vies et tous quand
on respecte les règles tous les jeunes
qui aujourd'hui respecte les gestes
barrière porte le masque même si c'est
difficile voie moins d'amis
indirectement il sauve des on a assez
peu d'occasions dans le monde d'être des
héros on a des occasions quand on est
médecin canton des pompiers quand on est
policier moi ce n'est pas mon cas et on
peut tous être des héros si on respecte
ses règles elle a ses règles là parce
que indirectement on protège les autres
et on sauve des vies on peut tous sauver
des vies et tous les jeunes qui se
mobilisent
le faire et ça je pense que c'est un
message positif optimiste qui précédent
tu peux rassembler la jeunesse le
message qu'on veut faire passer ce soir
dans cette émission et je le dis à tous
ceux qui nous regardent c'est
qu'aujourd'hui et ceux qui ont la clé
vraiment de peut-être pour éviter un
recond finement ce sont les plus jeunes
se sont comme voilà vous avez pris
l'exemple de cet anniversaire d
anniversaire il va en avoir des milliers
ce week-end et bien des anniversaires à
70 personnes dans un appart ou dans une
maison il faut les annuler voilà on fera
l'anniversaire plus tard les
anniversaires c'est tous les ans ou
alors on fera l'année prochaine par
définition non mais c'est voilà c'est ça
c'est ce qu'il faut faire passer comme
message c'est vraiment qu'aujourd'hui
c'est par les jeunes par les fêtes par
les rassemblements qu'on fait
qu'aujourd'hui on va avoir du mal à
juguler
voilà l à la contamination et c'est ce
que vous disiez tout à l'heure le virus
de la fête mois cette expression je
pense qu'il va rester aussi de cette
soirée
et c'est vous qui l'avez neigeux c'est
vrai que ça on l'avait jamais entendu
mais c'est remarque est déplorable et je
pense que ça voilà tous ceux qui nous
regardent ce soir
le virus de la fête pensez-y à chaque
moment s'arrête le week-end là qui va
arriver dès demain voilà respecter les
gestes barrière mettez vos masques et
c'est vrai que ça a été vraiment ça ça
va rester le virus doit fait oui oui
j'ai julie et l'isq c'est très important
de le dire de cette manière là gabriel
il faut vraiment à l'époque a brillé
alors ça y est vous c'est tranquille
valeur
non mais c'est très important le dire de
cette manière et mais il faut aller
aussi plus loin parce que ceux qui n'ont
pas regardé cette émission ne savent pas
vraiment et on a un petit peu perdues
les jeunes dansent dans ce combat on se
sent notre génération de jeunes un peu
invincible par rapport à ce virus soit
on l'a attrapé et on pense qu'on peut
plus le rattraper donc je sais peut-être
une question qu'on va vous poser après
monsieur le médecin de est ce qu'on peut
leur ai attrapé parce qu'il ya toute une
légende urbaine autour du de la récidive
du virus et et il faut vraiment je sais
pas peut-être en parler dans les écoles
ou dans les lycées dans les facs
matraquage pas des matchs et des choses
projet et vous réunir puisque on est
invité tous les soirs à d
à des soirées quoi c'est vrai que sur la
question la communication a les clés
pourquoi vous êtes là tous pourquoi
est-ce que cyril vous a invité parce que
vous avez tous des communautés vous êtes
suivi par d'autres jeunes vous êtes des
exemples pour d'autres jeunes je pense
qu'il y en a d'autres qui nous regardent
qui que ce soit avec des relais et donc
on a besoin de vous pour passer ses
messages sur vos réseaux sociaux
on essaye aussi le gouvernement d'être
innovant mois tous les jeudis sur mon
compte instagram je fais une session de
questions réponses avec les personnes
qui me suivent qui me posent des
questions en plus c'est par message donc
on n'a pas forcément n'a pas honte de
poser une question dont on dit qu'elle
est elle jette et j'essaye de répondre
plus de questions possibles
on essaye de développer ça mais on a
besoin aussi que des jeunes qui parlent
à d'autres jeunes s'en fassent les
relais est passé ses messages et juste
pourquoi vous n'avez pas inviter les 50m
fraîcheur fera danser toutes les
semaines de que pour leur dire voilà on
a besoin de vous faites passage dans la
rue non merci je parle du gouvernement
et je parle nous de ton post modern a
bien non le gouvernement mais de qu'avec
le premier ministre ne que y'a pas de
problème
non mais pourquoi voulez pas fait c'est
une idée ça mais ça y est le faire -
mais porte-parole a très bien le rendez
vous et vous mettrez à aller faire venir
parce que ils sont là bas je sais bien
mais si vous voulez vous voulez vous
faire monter semaine une réunion en
parallèle de la conférence de presse
classique qui est fait partie de la
vérité en face une réunion porte parolat
du gouvernement avec les influenceurs %
relayer les messages répondre aux
questions qui apparaissent à branco il
organise à partir à partir la semaine
prochaine mais c'est rien mais nous
alors nous arrêter les anniversaires at
on fait des réunions avec le match sur
la communication
j'ai un autre souci mais qui peut
forcément se régler jusqu'à moi
personnellement nous on a 26 ans on a
une entreprise on la fin à cette crise
je trouve que elle est bien gérée par
l'état français
financièrement cirque on s'est pas senti
dans la merde on se sent soutenu je me
sens évidemment on a plein de potes qui
sont en danger plein d'entreprises qui
terme aux rumeurs pour vous mais y en a
plein qui sont des biens sur lui quand
on regarde la situation par rapport à
des potes à nous qui habitent aux états
unis qui sont limite sur un nom mais il
a été très mal gérée voilà on recule on
sait ça va rassurer
par contre et c'est le ressenti de
beaucoup de mes abonnés et de beaucoup
de gens
parfois j'ai l'impression que vous
mitraillé mitraillé mitraille locaux
vides aux infos et limite vous délaissez
certains sujets en fait je pense que là
on est à l'aube d'un une nouvelle époque
d'un nouveau jour c'est l'occasion pour
nous deux
rien nouveau monde un truc trop stylé où
on est plus tous un peu des connards
voilà donc est ce que vous n'avez pas
envie d'adresser certains sujets puisque
on a vécu quand même des trucs de ouf
dans le monde ces derniers temps je
pense notamment à blake lively matters
chance aux violences faites aux femmes
je pense aux à l'impact écologique jeune
neymar au phénomène climatique aussi qui
se passe exactement ils sont juste un
label qui je vais régler week où vous
personnellement moi j'ai 26 ans je
consomme pas bfmtv je ne vous ai jamais
entendu parler des ouigours qui est en
fait un phénomène terrible d'internement
dans des camps de concentration de
musulmans en chine
et oui on en a parlé donc un pacte
écologique violences faites aux femmes
blacklight matters enfin c'est un
mouvement qui est mondial personne n'en
parle vraiment à part pour parler de
séparatisme je trouve ça trop dommage
mais est-ce qu'on va pas construire un
nouveau monde fait comme si au niveau de
la com de vous répondre
un nouveau monde hyper cool sur ces
sujets là julien juillet moi je moi je
me suis dit oui parce que je lui dis
laissez ça c'est pas pour moi c'est
julien ellis et ça c'est un crime on l
aime et non mais moi je vais vous dire
vous parlez de là vous parlez un peu
d'aidé des chaînes d'information parler
des grandes messes
voilà du 20h pouvoir sur tf1 sur france
2 c'est pas le gouvernement qui ne s'est
fâché il faut récupérer les gens non non
non ça se passait comme ça il ya
quelques années sur mais là ça c'est que
je pouvais demander les chercheurs
ombragé ou dire ils vont venir chercher
mais c'est très simple il faut que vous
sachiez un truc au journalisme on est
bien ce qui intéresse c'est ce qui se
passe en france
donc les journaux télévisés dépenses à
une chose exaucé faire c'est faire de
l'audience
les ouigours c'est un drame ce qui se
passe actuellement en chine
j'en ai parlé encore aujourd'hui sur mon
instinct j'ai vu qu'il ya beaucoup de
gens qui se sont mobilisés également
beaucoup de beaucoup d'artistes ça on
n'en parle pas parce que je vous dis ça
malouda manquent elles sont actives en
france quand on achète une paire de
baskets non mais bien sûr énorme énorme
et l'impact des esclaves mais leur
matière première et elle cherche un
coach que je vous dis le problème qu'on
a bien sûr aujourd'hui c'est que les
rédactions et c'est leur droit et elle
fonce à elles sont sur le sanctionner le
sensationnalisme elles veulent faire
peur elles disent qu est ce qui
intéresse les gens aujourd'hui c'est le
co vide c'est faire peur c'est dire
qu'il ya reconfirmant dire qu'on risque
voilà qui a de plus en plus de cas les
ouigours oui c'est un drame ce qui se
passe là bas
mais malheureusement on n'en parle pas
assez sur les chaînes d'info et sur les
grandes chaînes sur les grands médias
voilà vous avez parlé votre mouvement
le problème c'est que ça se passera en
france aujourd'hui aujourd'hui ce qui
intéresse les français et il pense
d'abord à leurs audiences il vous dit
6/10 bannu oui mais moi je parle pas le
français
je parle pas d'eux des gens qui
consomment bfm franchement je n'ai même
pas de télé chez moi je parle des jeunes
ouais on a juste besoin d'un petit je
vous ai compris parce que sur les sujets
qui nous en ce moment je sais pas si
vous êtes d'accord signé sa ion en fait
nous on a compris le coc vide je suis
prête à faire des efforts
je suis prête à ne plus aller en teuf
j'aimerais juste que bon déjà il ya un
peu plus de pédagogie sur ce sujet qu'on
nous explique clairement les choses en
mode limite si vous pouvez nous dire
typiquement une journée de citoyens
jeunes exemplaire c'est quoi j'aimerais
bien passage très bien mais je pense
qu'il ya aussi un enjeu qui est social
et sociétal si vous voulez pas que
demain les jeunes en fait il ne vous
écoutent plus et qu'ils votent pour des
extrêmes ben qui eux vont aller les
récupérer et dia et nous on vous écoute
sur ces sujets là parce que ce que c'est
eux qui vont écologique des masses
franchement en 2005 il ya des masques
partout ne serait-ce que chez moi y'a
genre 50 masques éparpillés partout je
sais même pas dans quelques jours et le
jeter si du plastique
enfin c'est une espèce de polystyrène
qui plairont pue de la gueule avec ce
truc même voilà c'est bien votre
témoignage sur sa merci 105 mo quoi
garde non mais je pense que vraiment il
faut pas oublier que ces sujets qui vous
intéressent aujourd'hui alors débarrassé
les violences policières c'est le sujet
du racisme
je sais que c'est incomparable existence
aux états unis et que j'ai pas du tout
envie d'entrer dans ce sujet voilà c'est
un automne je voulais revenir le sujet
la question des violences faites aux
femmes pendant confinement les violences
faites aux femmes a augmenté de 6%
qu'est ce qui est fait aujourd'hui
concret volery gsm les violences aussi
sur celle ci et je sais que vous faites
des choses mais je pense que vous les
communiquer au mauvais endroit parce que
je sais que castex il a fait un post par
exemple récemment repris à ses ex
premier ministre
il a fait un poste récemment pour dire
qu' il était allé donner de l'argent à
la maison des femmes qui est une maison
qui est des femmes victimes de violence
dans 93 franchement j'en ai jamais
entendu parler moi enfin vous ne vous
attaquez pas à nos canaux en fait donc
on n'entend pas parler d'autres qui sont
sûrement cool le plan de relance
je comprenais rien j'ai regardé vite
fait j'ai trouvé ça trop cool et je me
suis dit pourquoi je suis pas au courant
que finalement l'état c'est pas si nul
ce qu'ils font pourquoi vous en parlez
pas pourquoi vous venez pas nous
chercher
nous dire les gars on est là pour vous
je sais que ça va pas franchement est ce
soir d'ailleurs 90 en direct sur twitter
elle parlait mais ce bouquin aussi voilà
et on essaie autant à part l'ex quelques
vides mais prenez nous par bompard alors
des nous illustre agir là dessus et
d'inscrire tout à l'heure gabriel vous
disiez arrêté faire des fêtes et vous
éviterez des morts et moi ce jeu met
dans la tête d'un jeune je dis ouais
mais qui meurt quand même les gens qui
meurent on sait la moyenne d'âge ses 84
ans moi ce que je dis aux jeunes s'est
pas fait pas la fête parce que vous
allez vite et des marges dit c'est pas
la fête pour pas pourrir votre avenir
quoique et moi je suis content et
présentera des contaminations on parlera
du coc vide moi je voulais parler que
les jeunesses de bfm ok je vais souvent
mais ils vont essayer de faire autre
chose on essaie mais tout le monde veut
du coup vide je suis un condensé à
raison jugeait il arrive bien sûr le
comité ils ont essayé de lancer des
terroristes il a un goût de 24 heures
tout on s'en foutait les genres voulait
ducobu des mois ils m'invitent c'est ça
quand même
il a raison tout seul donc soumis de
communication copains vous êtes bien sûr
c'est de la communication il ya un temps
pour tout on peut parfois calais des
petits moments au fait c'est vrai qu'il
se passe des trucs très relou à une
femme meurt tous les deux jours sous les
coups de son conjoint va faire quelque
chose les ouigours fait c'est une
situation des packs monde et chaque jour
la chose à notre échelle jeudi le
docteur c'est que c'est la course à
l'audience et que aujourd'hui c'est le
kovi kovi kovi donc moi eh bien vous
avez d'aider des réseaux américains vers
la question et je suis désolé mais on
parle à la chine en tant que bien sûr en
tant qu' il a dit si on a l'impression
que même quand même du côté de rio
gouverneur on a l'impression que ce
sujet n'a jamais été soulevée dans les
relations avec la chine là que je
matière du différé attention cela sent
plus vraiment faire quelque chose mais
d'abord un mois je veux quand même dire
cyril a dit je vous remercie c'est pas
moi qui fais la ligne éditoriale des
médias et qui choisit des questions
qu'on va me poser quand je viens sur les
plateaux bien parfois j'aimerais bien
mais c'est pas moi qui le fais et sachez
le nous on en a rien préparé on ne
savait pas du tout les questions qu'elle
est posée donc vraiment moi moi je rêve
que d'une chose c'est de parler des
sujets dont vous parliez vous parlez de
la transition écologique avec le plan de
relance on met 33 milliards d'euros sur
le sujet alors 30 milliards d'euros ça
veut rien dire personne voit ce que ça
veut dire concrètement ça veut dire qu'à
des centaines de milliers de français
qui ont envie de faire des travaux chez
eux pour isoler leur logement pour que
ça consomme moins d'énergie
dire être mais mieux pour
l'environnement et en plus faire des
économies sur le pouvoir d'achat
on va leur financer leurs travaux
jusqu'à 20000 euros l'état va payer
jusqu'à 20000 euros pour ce que j'ai
envie de faire des travaux pour isoler
leur logement
on va investir des milliards d'euros
pour développer en france une nouvelle
énergie qui est l'hydrogène verts qui va
permettre de faire rouler des bus des
voitures et peut-être demain des avions
sans consommer d'énergie et sans polluer
comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui
donc tout ça moi j'adorerais en parler
malheureusement quand je vais dans les
médias ce n'est pas toujours sectaire
parfois évoqué tous les sujets sur
lesquels on m'interroge ensuite
évidemment moi j'essaye de communiquer
sur les réseaux sociaux gouvernement
aussi on a des comptes ce réseau sociaux
gouvernement moi j'ai mes comptes
j'essaye aussi d'alimenter dessus encore
une fois vous pouvez aussi relayé les
choses nous interroger moi si on
m'interroge je réponds toujours on a une
idée de karim zéribi tout à l'heure moi
je veux bien faire la prière toutes les
semaines et vous voulez que les semaines
après le conseil des ministres
je fais une conférence de presse devant
les journalistes où je répond à leurs
questions
et bien si vous voulez que je fasse la
même chose avec les influences leurs
réserves officielles pas bon qu on le
fait vous poserai toutes les questions
la marine nationale est libre lundi ce
que vous avez à lui anniversaire voilà
ça je suis dit voilà sur les rigoureux
vous allez on sur les we go est ce qu'on
peut pas voilà on en direct ce soir dès
23h10 ses timides et sur les ouigours
jeune ornais ce nom mais timidement
sortir la voix de la france on peut en
parler
est ce qu'on peut en parler voire et 6h
de la république pour ce qui pour qu'il
intervienne est ce qu'il est possible
d'intervenir en chine on sait que c'est
compliqué mais aujourd'hui ce qui se
passe en chine
c'est inadmissible c'est très grave est
vraiment c'est très grave tout ici en
france il ya plus en plus de gens qui
sont en train de se mobiliser et qui si
on parle et qui ont envie de faire
passer un message mais le seul qui peut
faire quelque chose aujourd'hui c'est le
président de la république emmanuel
macron est ce qu'aujourd'hui je suis sûr
qu'ils nous regardent les manuels
maintenant je perçois des kilos nous
regarder est ce qu'il est possible de
lui faire passer un message par votre
biais puisque vous n'êtes pas de parole
du gouvernement est d'essayer de faire
quelque chose au plus vite à son temps
le reste de la biélorussie que des
ouïghours alors il n'est pas normal de
faire passer un message
parce qu'il est totalement au courant de
la situation et qu'il est totalement
mobilisé sur la situation des migrants
moi je fais des médias toutes les
semaines personne ne pose la question
mais sinon je peux vous dire très
clairement un que le président l'a dit
il a écrit je le redis ici
la france elle condamne ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui avec les migrants c'est à
dire que c'est parce qu'on n'a pas dire
des camps d'internement
ces exactions des violences sexuelle et
reproductive du travail forcé on va de
la survaleur de la surveillance de masse
que les qui sont les ouigours 1 pour nos
téléspectateurs
voilà qui sont qui sont pas au courant
c'est vrai que elle en parlait il ya un
instant c'est une communauté musulmane
donc en en chine et c'est vrai qu'ils
sont persécutés sais vous allez vous
l'avez dit c'est une épuration c'est une
évaluation c'est sûr les choses c'est
c'est joli c'est c'est une horreur ce
qui se passe ça fait longtemps que ça
dure ça fait longtemps que ça dure
et là et c'est inquiétant moi je le dis
aussi serré mais c'est inquiétant quand
même que ce soit des gens county mettons
la larme sur ça ok les journalistes ne
pas poser des questions mais des fois
vous êtes des adultes pouvaient aborder
le sujet de vous même comme je vous dis
pas que l'on met la larme
alors justement et l alarme ont leur
sécurité des nations-unies la larme on
l'a depuis longtemps pour le saisit pas
mais coffrane le saisit alors à tanger
10,1
je le dis ou condamnés et quand la
france dit qu'elle condamne quelque
chose ça a quand même un certain poids
dans le concert international ssi de la
deuxième manche mais le conseil de
sécurité tous les organismes des nations
unies évidemment qu'on les saisies
évidemment elle fonctionne appris qu'en
droit charles x mais à chaque fois que
la france en a l'occasion
dans ces réunions on demande à ce qu'il
y ait des condamnations qu'ils soient
faites et à ce que les actions qu'ils
soient prises à chaque fois que des pays
propose un texte où le domaine des pas
fort par koh lanta ben je peux dire que
je peux vous dire que dans le temps dans
ces organismes on le demande à chaque
fois que des pays qui propose un texte
global de plusieurs pays pour condamner
prendre des mesures mais la france est
le signe elle essaye d'avancer
donc ça je veux dire on le fait à chaque
fois qu'on a l'occasion d'avoir des
échanges diplomatiques avec nos
homologues ou avec des responsables
diplomatiques chinois on a ce message là
deuxièmement et troisièmement est
aujourd'hui une chose sur laquelle on se
mobilisent parce que ça l'état peut le
faire directement
c'est aider les ouigours y en a pas
beaucoup mais qui sont aujourd'hui sur
le sol français parce qu'il y en a parce
qu'ils ont besoin d'avoir un titre de
séjour
parce que pour ça ils ont parfois besoin
de passer par le consulat en chine que
ça peut être très compliqué et donc on
fait des facilités pour permettre de
renouveler leur titre de séjour
ceux qui sont sur notre sol pour le coup
on sait ce qu'on peut faire gravir et là
bas le drame il est là bas
avant ici en france il ya plein de
choses à faire avec les marques lui
devoir de vigilance que raphaël
glucksmann essaye de faire voter en ce
moment à la commission européenne fin
c'est quelque chose c'est d'obliger les
marques à arrêter de faire partie des
classes que le seul truc qui peut
marcher avec le gouvernement chinois je
pense c'est minable les impacts et
économiquement c'est sûr cc avant ça ce
serait la solution oui dieu qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire clairement pour que
enfin qu'est ce que le gouvernement
français peut faire clairement pour que
tout ce qui se passe là bas ça s'arrête
alors je pense déjà que le gouvernement
français seul ça reste compliqué
justement et abriel à thales qui est pas
impossible d'aller voir peut-être
l'allemagne va livrer le nom de l'europe
a exactement au nom de l'europe donc
allé voir angela merkel voir ce qu'elle
en pense parce que si déjà toute
l'europe se mobilise et économiquement
et c'est d'impact et la chine
je pense que il va quand même avoir une
écoute
voilà parce qu'aujourd'hui je vois je
sais ce que fait raphaël glucksmann et
d'ailleurs bravo à lui
parce que c'est vrai qu'il a pris ça à
bras le corps et c'est vrai que
aujourd'hui si on ne sait pas d impact
économiquement je vois pas pourquoi ils
nous écouterait les guérillas thales que
vous avez des jeunes là on leur parle de
l'europe
on leur dit c'est une continent on a des
valeurs de marché si dans ces moments là
l'union européenne ne parle pas d'une
seule voix
comment vous voulez a marqué la jeunesse
dans l'espérance d'une union européenne
qui est porteuse de valeurs et ce n'est
pas capable de le faire
j'ai totalement amoral et qu'ils y
croient et moi je suis de cette
génération qui a grandi en entendant en
permanence que l'europe ça marchait pas
et que ça pouvait rien faire mais on le
démontre un accord sera sur le sujet une
question sur sur ce sujet là mais on se
bat pour essayer de ramener des pays
autour de nous ça se fait pas en un
claquement de doigts et je pense que ça
payera
je pense que ça finira par payer
deuxièmement cette crise si on revient
sur le sujet d'avant je veux bien rester
sur ce sujet mais cette crise a quand
même permis de montrer que l'europe elle
pouvait faire des choses ce qu'on a
réussi à faire
tout à l'heure on en parlait sur le plan
de relance c'est à dire avoir une europe
qui lève de l'argent qui développe ses
propres ressources pour venir en aide
aux pays à ses états membres
c'est totalement louise accord sur le
remboursement de la dette mais c'est pas
encore il ya quelques années ça aurait
été jamais envisageable jamais les pays
membres de l'union européenne et
notamment l'allemagne
n'aurait accepté ça parce que le
président s'est mobilisée depuis trois
ans qu'il a travaillé là dessus et que
ça porte ses fruits aujourd'hui qu'on
est capable d'arriver à ça et moi je
suis persuadé que sur des sujets comme
celui qu'on évoquait sur les mi lourds
ça finira par payer ça finira mal il
averti alors qu'au niveau national il ya
urgence c'est mignon je vous dis vous
avez le sentiment que ça donne que si
c'était une autre communauté qui étaient
touchés
je sais pas moi peut-être on en parlait
des chrétiens d'orient moi j'ai été
touché de ce qui se passait pour les
chrétiens d'orient
moi je trouvais normal qu'on aille les
défunts dans leur secours pour les
sauver de quai mais c'est même pas un
sujet la question et c'est qu'on se dit
là bas si une communauté musulmane
toutefois s'en fout de coalition mais
c'est l'impression que ça donnerait je
lance avec la même force légale manière
donc contre l'injustice pas contre une
ou pour une communauté en particulier
contre l'injustice c'est ça la grandeur
de la france
c'est juste y la lie à lomé où la
médaille la ya urgence
il ya urgence gabriela talent alors ça
mais nous rapprocher des sujets creux
vide en plus les jeunes ça va les
sensibiliser de savoir que ben il
s'adresse à un lycéen qui finalement les
comprend on va se dire bon ils sont là
cd sans ses frères
on les écoute on arrête de faire la teuf
et je le dis de façon très très très
grosse heure très facile mais c'est une
question de communication parce que je
n'ai aucun doute sur le fait que vous
avez des équipes pour avoir rencontré
pas mal de personnes au sein du
gouvernement qu'ils comprennent les
choses qu'ils savent qu'ils sont mieux
que beaucoup d'autres personnes qu'on a
à côté en politique juste dit l'éditeur
dit on est là on est avec vous il va se
passer des choses peut-être je fais quoi
ce soir je suis là pour ses chants mais
bah bravo mais voilà ces champs mais
quand je cherche mais la raison de ces
changements
non mais c'est vrai on a raison
demandent si vous venez l'agent bien
j'aimerais parce qu'eric naulleau qui va
faire le débrief dans l'instant
j'aimerais y gabriela talent qu'on
s'adresse à nos téléspectateurs qu'on
s'adresse aux jeunes qui nous regardent
et que vous leur disiez quelles sont les
règles qu'il faut respecter dans les
prochains jours qu'est ce qu'on risque
est ce que si on respecte ses règles
on pourra éviter leur confinement
j'aimerais que vous vous adressiez à eux
vous leur disais voilà fassiez passer le
message
c'est le hashtag protège tes potes qu'on
a lancé la semaine dernière
parce que là c'est bientôt le week-end
qu'est ce que vous avez à leur dire moi
je le redis ce que j'ai dit dès le début
de cette émission est ce que je
dis là c'est que les jeunes ça a été des
héros pendant le confinement et ça peu
et ça doit rester des héros pendant la
période qu'on est en train de vivre vous
avez la possibilité parce que vous allez
faire des efforts et tout le monde qu'on
soit que c'est difficile vous avez la
possibilité d'aider le pays à s'en
sortir et d'aider des personnes à ne pas
mourir ça c'est vrai et comme l'a dit le
docteur et je rejoins totalement cet
argument aider aussi à construire votre
avenir
parce que quand on parle du coc vite qui
dure quand on parle de la crise
économique c'est les jeunes qui seront
les premiers les premiers impactés si la
crise économique elle perdure donc c'est
la possibilité de prendre ses
responsabilités et d'avoir un impact
très concret sur son avenir en étant
responsable être responsable c'est quoi
c'est aujourd'hui respecté les consignes
sanitaires
voilà c'est concrètement c'est quoi
aussi sait pas on évite les
anniversaires un port du masque et les
fêtes et ruby un port du masque avec une
règle c'est olivier ferrand pour le coup
j'avais trouvé ça assez bon moment en
com qui avait eu cette formule il avait
dit le masque c'est abcd faut savoir le
porte et quand c a b c d
ah c'est quand on est à risque quand on
a des maladies en par ailleurs et cbc
quand on est dans un lieu bondé
c'est quand on est dans un lieu clos et
d'essai quand on veut pas faire la
distance avec quelqu'un d'autre ou qu'on
soit voilà bon c'est au moins ça a le
mérite de la clarté je vous vois rien
docteur mais ça le mérite d'alerter des
voix là ça va rester aussi ça donc ça
c'est léger rebond est pratique mais
russe de la fête
c'est ça le mérite d'être l'un virus
aura fait hashtag combattre le virus de
la salsa le mérite d'être virale alors
on premièrement le masque deuxièmement
les gestes barrière la distance le
lavage des mains régulier à la faire
attention à pas être toujours les uns
coller aux autres et 3 réduire autant
que possible le nombre de contacts
sociaux qu'on a on va essayer de pas
voir des dizaines des vins d'été
centaines de personnes différentes
voilà essayer de voir un peu les mêmes
personnes si la 18ème chercheurs et
respect l'année limite à 20 30
honnêtement qui me paraît raisonnable et
caissargues calculer c'est une fête à 20
30 c'est possible parce qu'on va pas
vous empêcher de faire la fête
complètement mais 20 30 l'extérieur
c'est toujours mieux la terrasse est
toujours mieux quand ça va réouvrir et
au delà de 20 30 ont annulé on attend la
prochaine fois et peut-être qu'en
gouvernement organisera une énorme fête
pourtant des hommes quand la crise sera
finie et on se rattrapera commission
espère on espère qu'on sera vite et on
espère couvrir non mais voilà que les
fils moins vite et que tu as trahi a
très vité alors j'aimerais qu'on pose
maintenant une petite rafale de
questions à notre à notre secrétaire
d'état il y avait des questions qui va
être posée la marque était dans le
public patrons de discothèques qui vous
dit est ce que vous pensez vraiment
qu'on va pouvoir renaître on a une mort
programmée
les discothèques il est extrêmement
inquiet marqué ou marquent mark mark mc
marque salut marque merci d'être là
owona micro c'est vrai que votre
question c'est est ce que vous pensez
vraiment qu'on va pouvoir en est on à
une mort programmée les discothèques
c'est une catastrophe pour vous oui
c'est une catastrophe
un chiffre pour commencer un
établissement disparaît tous les deux
jours voilà à l'heure actuelle on à 1600
discothèque au début du coc vide le 13
mars et suite à la fermeture
administrative qui est sans précédent
nous sommes à l'heure actuelle avec déjà
sans confrères sans collègues qui nous
ont perdu la question elle est
évidemment légitime
on a eu quelques z au début comme toutes
les entreprises et là à l'heure actuelle
on nous sommes dans la tente des
promesses qui nous sommes qui nous sont
faites par non et on se bat de manière
quotidienne pour essayer encore de se
faire entendre car on a quand même un
énorme problème c'est que toute cette
nouvelle génération qu'on voit autour de
nous nous ne la connaissons pas c'est à
dire que la génération des 18 ans des
lycéens et autres
nous n'avons encore pas côtoyer
là on parle du régime d'exception
repoussé maintenant jusqu'en avril si
c'est voté six et validé en avril 2021
on attaquera la deuxième génération qui
ne nous connaîtrons pas la question
c'est ce que ce que la jours avant qu'on
enchaîne les question c'est est-ce que
vous pensez que les patrons de
discothèques comme de nuit va revoir le
mode bon travail est d'abord je sais que
vous êtes dans la difficulté des places
je rencontre des patrons de discothèques
et je vous remercie d'avoir dit que dès
le début il ya des mesures qui ont été
prises pour vous soutenir
j'étais en déplacement à strasbourg la
bayanne discothèque a reçu quatre cent
mille euros en tout des dents entre le
chômage partiel le prêt garanti par
l'état le fonds de solidarité
le prêt c'est un prêt c'est un prêt de
laisser une aide ces garanties par
l'état
justement pour que vous puissiez en
bénéficier deuxièmement c'est vrai que
vous attendiez des nouvelles mesures
et alors je vous l'avez peut-être pas vu
parce que c'est vraiment tombé
aujourd'hui pour le coup ici on les
on les a épluché alors ce pour le pire à
des grecs est sorti je veux préciser je
décrète ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
qu'une discothèque qui est fermée
aujourd'hui elle va recevoir à partir de
maintenant et même de manière
rétroactive pour les mois qui se sont
écoulés
quinze mille euros par mois c'est pas un
prêt c'est le subventions de l'état
quinze mille euros par mois pour tenir
en plus on lui supprime ses charges et
en plus on continue avec le chômage
partiel à indemniser ses salariés quinze
mille euros par mois une discothèque
comme la vôtre qui est fermé depuis
plusieurs mois déjà si elle fait la
demande
elle va recevoir 45000 euros pour les
trois derniers mois la demande est déjà
effectués on a déjà au deuxième degré au
dessus créé là dessus et pour le moment
l'inscrit d'instruction n'a pas été
encore faite juste pour le pg on va nous
donner à un moment une date de reprise
une date de remboursement du pg ça se
trouve nous n'aurons pas retravailler
non mais ça roule pour le pg on le met
juste deux côtés on n'en parle plus
d'accord ça c'était le fait je donc
ensuite voilà les 15000 euros on les
attend il y aura une autre aide qui sera
déduite de ces fameux trois fois quinze
mille euros mais là en l'heure actuelle
vous savez quand on dit c'est une
discothèque qui disparaît tous les deux
jours et quand on se bat et quand on
vient au créneau qu'on fait des actions
quotidiennes
il y en a énormément c'est qu'il faut
aller il faut aller vite voilà on
disparaît on est en train de disparaître
mais ce que je vous dis c'est donc il ya
cette nouvelle est de 15000 euros qui
sort à partir d'aujourd'hui d'ailleurs
j'ai vu les déclarations du président du
syndicat des patrons de discothèques qui
s'est dit satisfait qu'ils aient dit
enfin on a été entendu après des mois de
discussions faut aussi le dire quand les
choses ne se débloquent et qu'elles vont
bien ça arrive peut-être parfois un peu
tard mais c'est important c'est
important de le dire
alors on a vous disais tout à l'heure
moi je suis sûr que la nuit reverra le
jour
c'est là c'est joli comme fera pas se
faire que même l'espère que les jeunes
qui la connaissent pas les discothèques
baril et découvriront et on sera là pour
leur dire à quel point c'est sympa
d'aller en boîte
s'il faut se donnerait même l'exemple
quand tout ça aura rouvert et concernant
l'une d'après les huîtres ingéré dans
votre discothèque g20 voyait mais d une
bouteille c'est pour vous inscrire si on
tue non merci
est-ce qu'on a des questions pensez vous
que nous pourrons faire le repas de noël
en famille et oui alors bah oui bien sûr
oui bien sûr on peut faire l'europe a
passionné ici entre 20 et en magasin
mais est ce qu'il ya où il est placé
ouais la france allait rejoindre sa
famille et il le sait passe à al ahly
aujourd'hui ça n'est pas aujourd'hui à
rien qu'il me permets de vous dire sûr
qu'on ne pourra pas faire noël en
famille voilà il ya rien qui vous permet
de dire vous dire on va faire nous
allons faible
aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'on sait ce qu'on
veut quand c'est la société de l'inconnu
je veux dire il y en a qui ont essayé au
début de cette crise de dire je vous
garantis que dans deux mois et se
passera si on a vu le résultat
mais en tout cas on fait tout pour ça et
si on est autour d'une table en famille
on garde ses distances notamment des
plus vulnérables le grand-père la grand
mère qu'on évite d'aller voilà leur
faire trop de bisous etc oui c'est
possible lui concevoir j'aimerais bien
que vous demander au ministre pourquoi
on ne referme pas les frontières car la
seconde vague est arrivée après les
retours de vacances
pourquoi on ne referme pas les
frontières puisque c'est ce qu'on lui
demande d'abord rien ne permet de dire
que le virus il est arrivé depuis les
frontières qu'il arrivait depuis
l'extérieur d'accords à long terme il a
continué à circuler à bas bruit en
france ait eu un moment où il a beaucoup
repris en mayenne
au coeur de l'été pas considérer que ça
soit les traverser des frontières qui
fait reprendre le virus en maille à une
première manche deuxièmement fermer les
fermer les frontières c'est un impact
très concret pour beaucoup de nos
concitoyens qui sont ce qu'on appelle
des travailleurs frontaliers des gens
qui habitent à la frontière de pays qui
sont voisins qui vont tous les jours ils
traversent la frontière pour aller
travailler je crois qu'ils sont 400
mines dans notre pays donc ça veut dire
vous leur dites vous arrêter de
travailler et ça on veut pas le on veut
pas le faire et enfin quand on regarde
les pays voisins il n'y a pas de pays où
le virus circule 10 x 15 x ou 100 fois
plus qu'en france et qui serait à des
dangers particuliers y circulent à des
degrés différents
de la même manière chez nos voisins
question suivante
sur twitter les chéris merci à voilà ils
sont bloqués cc 8
merci pourquoi ne pas obliger les
entreprises le permettant de télétravail
et ça vous en avez parlé tout à l'heure
c'est ce que vous allez privilégier de
plus en plus on sait ce qu'on recommande
fortement
auxerre est ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure vous le disiez vous même toutes
les entreprises peuvent pas faire télé
travailler tout le monde on est s'est
pas toujours possible voilà mais on
recommande fortement notamment la cei
beaucoup d'évolutions s'est beaucoup
développée questions merci c'est long un
gabriel c'est juste ici pensez vous
qu'il ya plus de danger dans les
magasins alimentaires où il ya beaucoup
plus de monde qu'au restaurant
tiens ça c'est une question s'il voit
beaucoup passé aussi bas le médecin l'a
peu je préfère que vous regarde son
masque quand on fait les courses quoi
alors que quand vous mangez vous pouvez
pas garder masqué encore une fois ça
s'est vérifié
c'est assez logique mois mais la
distanciation alors justement là romain
joffre le restaurateur dans le public
notre restaurateur marseillais
il est là mon romain barras lève toi mon
romain voilà qui est là depuis le début
romain
lui galère il a été frappé de plein
fouet il a perdu toute sa trésorerie
pauvres aux mains voilà pendant le
confinement et le pôle eaux restantes
pourra tenir que quelques semaines sans
revenu saas est un exemple et ce à des
exemples comme ça il y en a des dizaines
et des dizaines et ça même s'il ya
beaucoup d' aide de l'état
il pourra pas se relever et romain donc
romain vous avez une question pour notre
secrétaire d'état messieurs servile et
il a déjà bien bien avancé sur la
question tout à l'heure mais toi un
message à passer on est beaucoup investi
à marseille dans les manifestations on a
un syndicat qui s'appelle l'umih qui est
vachement investir qui a parlé aussi
tout allez vous parliez les clusters
dans les yeux dans le micro mouvement
dans les universités
il ya une tribune qui est sorti de 300
médecins hier ou avant-hier 300 médecins
de la région et le dr raul n'y ait pas
de dents qui parlait plus rauque et
soeur ils viennent des universités moi
le seul message que j'ai envie de poser
enfin d'essayer de ses axes de réflexion
vous dites que les jeunes aujourd'hui
c'est un problème de les encadrer de
leur faire passer un message
vous nous avez stigmatiser d'une
certaine manière nous ferment les
premiers vous nous avez ouvert les
dernières vous nous avez imposé en
ouvrant des mesures qui étaient
disproportionnés au départ on vous a
écouté vous a fait confiance
on a voulu être entre guillemets des
partenaires auprès de vous pour lutter
contre le coc vide essayer de fournir un
cadre est de protéger nos clients zain
énormément du rayon on a mis beaucoup de
moyens et moi par exemple j'ai mis des
portes automatiques des serviteurs de
partout on a aménagé l'extérieur avec
des chauffages pour prévenir l'hiver et
garder cette distanciation même si on
est amené à réouvrir l'intérieur qu'est
ce que vous dites des entreprises qui
ont fait tout ça et honnêtement je vous
donnais mon témoignage à marseille il ya
peut-être des creux et des collègues ou
des confrères qui vont m'en vouloir
comment vous voulez que nos travaux et
des mesures pour la mise en oeuvre elle
soit légitime r alors qu'il ya eu aucun
contrôle
a marseille nous n'avons pas eu de
contrôle c'est ce qu'on avait espéré un
lien vous avez des confrères à nous qui
aurait été ouverte ce soit sur le vieux
port dans mon quartier aux yeux à la vue
de tous a pignon sur rue et quand vous
êtes à ma place d'un v6 et 20,30 peu
importe même 1000 euros ça peut être
beaucoup pour une entreprise vous avez à
côté une entreprise qui a pas respecté
qui est pas content bien sûr n'est pas
sanctionné vous imaginez
sentiment est derrière le couperet la
fermeture alors qu'on pourrait être à
vos côtés - quand les jeunes viennent
dans mon restaurant les oblige à porter
le masque ils ont une distanciation il
partait une certaine heure le soir donc
après ça leur évite d'aller dans
certains endroits déjà quand vous sortez
jusqu'à minuit et que vous travaillez
dans demain quand vous êtes allés au
restaurant que vous avez contre eux vous
avez respecté les contrôles vous êtes
déjà moins tentés d'aller ailleurs nous
nous on est là pour vous aider dans
cette démarche là on a mis en place des
leurs et jouer je vois là on a joué le
jeu on investit on est l'une des
professions on est d'ailleurs le premier
jeu proche d'un des premiers employeurs
de france on est un gros acteur du
rassemblement social
donc aujourd'hui on a notre rôle à jouer
dans la crise et je pense que vous nous
avez fermé et dans un sens on n'a pas
été écouté vous avez perdu notre
confiance surtout par la communication
qui a été faite avec monsieur c'est ce
qui est en train de dire aux 25000
emplois marseille sait ce qu'il en reste
est ce qui ressort aussi romain c'est
qu'ils lisent
il ya beaucoup de restaurateurs qu'ils
on a joué le jeu on a voulu vraiment
être avec vous pour essayer de combattre
cette crise du coc vide on a mis les
moyens en oeuvre et aujourd'hui vous
nous lâcher c'est un petit peu ce qui
revient et il ya une perte de confiance
ils disent on a là on s'est dit on va
avancer main dans la main avec le
gouvernement on va écouter ce qu'ils
nous disent on va essayer vraiment de
faire exactement à la lettre qu on nous
a demandé et aujourd'hui on nous lâche
et on va se retrouver dans une situation
déplorable alors qu'est ce que vous
dites là ces gens qui ont une perte de
confiance vous n'avez pas distinguer
ceux qui respectaient les règles de ceux
qui les respectent pas c'est ça le
problème est le manque de moyens je
pense qu'avoir les du manque de moyens
dans les hôpitaux
je pense que le moine de moyens dans la
police quand on voit cet été qu'ils ont
été inexistantes de part dans mon
quartier et que là maintenant on est au
mois de septembre qui a plus personne
dans les rues convoi des camions de crs
de partout on a de quoi se poser des
questions quand le colisée avant-hier il
a ouvert il était seul à ouvrir le
pauvre parce qu'il a transgressé les
lois et je n'encourage pas à ça mais il
y avait 18 et au bout d'une demi heure
des camions de crs alors que cet été je
dis vous avez des réseaux sociaux et des
rassemblements il y avait des exemples
sur la perte de confiance gabriela tabou
dit vous n'avez pas distinguer les bons
et c'est vrai que dans la situation
on a distingué les endroits le virus
circule parce que ya pas de masque et un
endroit où le virus circule moi parce
qu'elle masque
et moi j'entends parfaitement ce que
vous dites moi d'abord ce que je veux
dire je le connais le secteur de la
restauration geoffroy retrait en
témoigner sert hazard
j ai beau cgt serveurs pendant plusieurs
années pendant mes études je sais ce que
c'est je sais que les restaurateurs ils
font des efforts et ce qu'ils veulent
apporter c'est le meilleur service
possible à leurs clients et qui veulent
protéger leurs clients qui veulent leur
faire plaisir et qui sont pas là pour
leur faire prendre des risques je sais
aussi que depuis le début de cette crise
vous avez fait des efforts que vous avez
parfois ça vous a coûté de l'argent vous
êtes équipé que vous avez fait en sorte
de permettre la distanciation parfois
vous avez réduit le nombre de couverts
pour voir garantir les distances et que
tous ces efforts là ils ont été faits
moi ce que je peux vous dire c'est deux
choses c'est un évidemment qu'on va
continuer à vous accompagner
si vous pouvez pas rouvrir je parlais
des 15000 euros tout à l'heure pour
monsieur qui à la discothèque les quinze
mille euros c'est aussi pour les
restaurateurs dont on ferme le
restaurant ses 15000 euros sur le mois
de subventions et ça sera le cas pour
les bars si on ferme les bars aussi vous
donne quinze mille euros en plus de
l'exonération de charges en plus du
chômage partiel pour vos salariés
et deuxième chose ce qu'a annoncé
olivier ferrand tout à l'heure c'est
qu'il va y avoir un travail dans les
jours qui viennent avec lui ni avec tout
les syndicats à tout ce qui représente
les restaurateurs pour qu'on propose un
nouveau protocole sanitaire contrats
validés au scientifique du haut conseil
de la santé publique qui peut-être
permet d'être encore plus sécurisant et
peut-être faudra l'accompagner d'un
engagement de l'état à contrôler
davantage à développer les contrôles je
pense que ça peut être une piste est là
et il est représentants des
restaurateurs ils sont en train de
travailler
ils vont faire des propositions au
gouvernement dans les jours qui viennent
on va les regarder ensemble on va les
faire ou scientifique et vos conseils à
la santé publique
et s'ils disent banco mans pourra
maintenir et restaurants ouverts avec
ces nouvelles règles sanitaires
il a parlé de ce week-end le ministre de
la santé que les propositions de la
profession serait sur la table ce
week-end parce que dimanche quand même
les sept jours se termine pour les
restaurants marseillais dont on espère
qu'il y aura pas de prolongation de
fermeture et que les propositions de la
profession ne seront prises en
considération pour le dire et ouvrir
avec une nouvelle commission
non seulement s'engage à faire un point
sur marseille bout de sept jours donc
dimanche et en plus on va avoir des
décisions à prendre pour paris
probablement si la situation ne change
pas pour lundi donc dimanche ça il ya
rachida mbarki qui est dans le public
propriétaire d'une salle de sport une
salle de fitness depuis cinq ans à
vincennes et je crois qu'en plus d'être
une amie de la famille
c'est ça ça c'est ça la vie d'amy une
amie de ma mère
voilà entendez bien voilà donc ça m'a
fait plaisir je m'entendais savoir
comment le voir sa valve a bien le temps
de leur téléphone vous l'entraîner oui
oui de temps en temps ça m'arriverait
non là ça coach quand même non c'est
vrai qu'elle est plus forte de la côte
ça promet merci rachida donc gérante
d'une salle de fitness et vous êtes
inquiète enchaînera très inquiètes oui
parce qu'aujourd'hui je enfin on ne
comprend pas pourquoi les salles de
sport sont prises pour cibles étant
donné qu'aujourd'hui on nous martèle
toute la journée à la télé que faire du
sport ça fait partie de des conditions
qui sont qui doivent être prises pour
garder une bonne santé
et aujourd'hui je suis convaincu on est
convaincu qu'aujourd'hui le sport fait
partie de la solution plus hot du
problème et aujourd'hui enfin vous
parliez tout à l'heure de du problème du
fait que les adhérents voilà une fois
qu'ils sont dans la salle il ya le
système de une fois qu'on enlève le
masque on a on a la possibilité de
projeter dans l'air enfin bon tout ça ça
reste de la théorie mais en pratique est
ce que vous avez des chiffres à nous
donner puisque vous avez recensé des
clusters en france ce que vous avez
salle de sport en voilà pour les salles
de sport on nous on n'est pas
réfractaire à toute vos décisions ne
sais pas ils ont fait des efforts aussi
voilà le gros des restaurateurs voilà
nous ferait pareil on l'a pris un petit
peu comme une punition collective dans
le sens où nous aujourd'hui on se bat on
se bat avec nos propres adhérents ont on
essaie de faire respecter au maximum
toutes les conditions que vous nous
mettez on est totalement soumis à ce que
vous me demandez de faire
on est un peu démunis et on a
l'impression que vous détenez tous à
retenir entre vos mains et ses airs
achille à l'ailé comme nos restaurateurs
ils on a fait beaucoup d'efforts on
s'est dit on veut pas être sanctionné
une deuxième fois on va mettre tous les
moyens en oeuvre pour essayer de
respecter les règles et où va investir
pour que ça se passe bien et aujourd'hui
ils ont l'impression que c'est une
sanction qui est tombé là c'est la
semaine dernière et qui va leur faire
très très mal il ya un chiffre monsieur
le ministre
26 millions de passages depuis le mois
d'août dans les salles de sport 2,5
carrosse et le cerveau le coup de les
fermer les plusieurs shows ce tour c'est
la vie ça vaut le coup de le faire mille
c'est la question fait premièrement vous
avez dit on s'en prend au salon vous
prenez aux salles de sport on s'en prend
pas de salle de sport se prend pas de
restaurant on s'en prend pas aux barres
on s'en prend aux virus c'est la seule
chose c'est la seule personne entre
guillemets à qui on s'en prend et donc
on met des restrictions quand c'est
nécessaire et quand on a malheureusement
pas le choix sur les lieux ou parce
qu'il ya pas de port du masque le virus
circule le plus et salles de sport parce
qu'à pas de port du masque parce que on
respire fortement qu'on va sortir des
gouttelettes de la sueur si mal premier
point
deuxième point je le dis quand même
puisque je les dis pour les autres
évidemment vous accompagne ce que j'ai
dit tout à l'heure sur les conditions
financières d'accompagnement
évidemment que ça s'applique aux salles
de sport en fait ça s'applique à tous
les lieux ont fermé administrativement
c'est à dire tous les lieux à qui on dit
vous devez fermer
point barre et troisièmement il ya ce
chiffre qui circule c'est ça moi on m'a
invité à le prendre avec des pincettes
je sais pas ce que vous en pensez
le médecin je crois qu'il ya une chaîne
de salles de sport qui a communiqué sur
un chiffre pour ses adhérents
mais la hyène débat il ya un débat
scientifique gpd plateau d'iraty fille
qu il reprenne ce changement ce chiffre
il est totalement faux en fait je peux
savoir une chose c'est qu'on sait
absolument pas où les cas au lieu c'est
à dire que y'a même pas 3% des 4 go vide
qui sont identifiés à un endroit et les
seuls endroits où on identifie ses les
entreprises des universités les écoles
parce qu'à des déclarations obligatoires
donc c'est totalement faux et les études
japonaises américaines européennes
montrent qu'à trois endroits où le virus
circule de plus c'est les bars les
restaurants les salles de sport et les
fêtes privées mais l'effet plus vous
pouvez rien contrôler donc c'est vrai
que s'il y avait aussi moins deux des
normes fait clandestins et ça ça c'est
qu'on aurait pu faire ça c'est bien
possible de retrouver le soir alors et
est donc qu'est-ce qu'on peut répondre à
rachida non mes fans c'est important ce
qui bien sûr que nos chiffres déjà fait
savoir déchiffrer faudrait tout ce qu'il
faudrait que tous ceux qui sont
contaminés dans la salle de sport un le
sache on sait qu'il ya beaucoup d'armes
automatiques et de et comme premier
réflexe d'appeler leur salle de sport
pour lui dire attention j'ai eu le
qu'ovide dans les écoles c'est sûr qu'il
ya un réflexe qu'on appelle ne peut pas
ça veut pas savoir mais il ya une étude
il ya des études asiatiques des études
européennes qui montre que c'est un lieu
ou un message utile
un escroc dis moi j'ai à la danse et un
toît grâce à ce qu'elle peut à la danse
elle me dit non c'est pas fermer ici ne
voit là les piscines donc voilà donc ça
ça va être fermée aussi commencé à se
presser dans mais enfin c'est toujours
pareil on s'appuie sur ce que disent les
jeux répondent à la danse parce qu'en
fait ce qu'ils ont fait c'est dans les
cesu cela ils ont pris des gens qui ont
été contaminés par le col vide
ils ont pris des gens qu'on pas été
contaminés lors ont posé des questions
sur qu'est ce que vous avez fait dans
les quinze derniers jours ait eu tous
les lieux et les piscines et les scènes
de danse ya accord cola est lé seul truc
qui sont ressortis mais bien sorti c'est
les restaurants les balais et sacs de
sport tous les autres y avait aucune
différence dire que les gens qui ont
attrapé le coville était pas plus à
l'est dans les autres que les gens qui
avaient pas le commis et c'est de là que
ça sort et tous les bons 10h tous les
pays sa ligne là dessus c'est à dire que
les bars et les restaurants s'est fait
dans tous les autres pays d'europe
oui c'est en mesure sa mesure du 10
lancers ça se conclut ce que vous dites
mais ces deux sondages qui nous a dit
derrière eux on ne prend pas en compte
alors ce qui nous dit derrière je me
souviens tu sais quoi c'est l'histoire
des clusters magie diversité non non non
ce qui nous dit derrière en gros vous
êtes en train de nous dire que les
restaurants sont éventuellement lieu de
contamination
mais quand vous respectez les mesures
d'ici les invités des pxg et que je
tombe vous êtes tous mais il faut il ya
quelque chose il ya quelque chose qui a
changé pendant l'été peut-être que ses
valises on en parlait tout à l'heure
c'est l'aérosol c'est à dire que la
distance ne suffit pas sa cause et
mettaient plein de micro particules dans
l'air de virus et après elles peuvent se
balader jusqu'à vous et vous contaminer
ce qu'ils avaient à dire qu'aulas vous
pouvez envoyer bien sûr mais bien sûr ça
alors pourquoi on fait l'émission un
surplus traduction les tabelles
mexicaine truc qui peut se retrouver
dans des restos on le fait ce soir mais
excusez moi mais juste d'abord merci
glace non mais joue en fait c'est un
petit peu on le prend comme une
injustice totale
ben ouais normal on fait on fait
vraiment partie de tournoi fait partie
de la solution pas du problème c'est
celle du sport c'est la santé vous êtes
les premiers à dire vous les médecins le
gouvernement lui aussi évidemment je
veux dire et donc c'est pour ça mais
c'est pour ça qu'on va vous soutenir
parce que dès qu'on sera ça sera
derrière nous on espère le plus
rapidement possible c'est aussi parce
qu'on prend des mesures difficiles on
peut se dire que ça arrivera plus
rapidement derrière nous je peux vous
dire que les français vont retourner
dans les salles de sport et on les
encourage à l'ouvrir d'extra qu'elle
commet les entourages
soir si c'était ce soir s'il était
nécessaire vous vous rendez compte que
les traditions envie de travailler
ouais parce que personne et pour la
fermeture mais c'est ce que je les
discothèques le beausset les bars ils
veulent bosser bosser les salles de soin
d'effacer un baume au coeur de métier
plus qu'ils veulent pas bosser ça vous
et mancini ce que les jeunes veulent pas
posée merci rachida et vous embrasser ma
mère que je verrai demain je
l'embrasserai également de vote pas
j'aimerais qu'on fasse un petit point
maintenant pour pour cette fin
d'émission priorat le débrief avec eric
naulleau cure encore d'autres
intervenants qui n'ont pas pu intervenir
cette première partie qui vont nous
donner des témoignages juge est vrai que
rudy gobert et just ryad
voilà et rudy gobert vous êtes un
immense champion j'aimerais savoir
qu'est ce que vous avez retenu ce soir
et quel message vous avez à faire passer
aux jeunes qui nous écoutent et qui vous
écoute parce que c'est vrai que vous
êtes un exemple
qu'est ce que vous avez envie de leur
dire ce soir pour qu'on évite d'être
confiné et qu'on se dise là on a quinze
jours
il faut vraiment qu'on soit tous
ensemble dans la même direction et on
essaie vraiment de respecter les gestes
barrières et qu'on ait cette phrase en
tête ce que ce virus c'est le virus de
la fête os x que ça va leur dire je
dirais continuer de s'éduquer à avoir
ces conversations avec des membres du
gouvernement et des des violeurs des
docteurs et c'est très important parce
que les jeunes ne savent pas bien sûr on
leur dit quoi faire mais savent pas
pourquoi être positif aussi parce que
c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de peur et
beaucoup de voix l'aller c'est un
certain pour beaucoup de business pour
beaucoup de jeunes pour leur avenir
je n'imagine la 18 ans une information
avec mon rêve de jouer à un billet c'est
compliqué donc j'ai la chance d'avoir ep
on est sorti aujourd'hui d'être là où
chez meiway est positif je pense que
c'est vraiment important et prendre les
mesures nécessaires j'ai appris des
choses ce soir j'ai appris des choses
j'ai appris des choses j'ai appris
beaucoup sur les situations de certaines
personnes et aussi sur les mesures du
gouvernement c'est just réac et qu'à une
voix qui porte énormément comme tout le
monde ici vous avez tout seul voilà ce
tous parlé tous essayé de faire passer
des messages et c'est just riyad est
extrêmement suivi voilà tout ce que je
t'adore c'est vrai voilà plaisir merci
frère françois il se sait vraiment et je
sais que tu as voile porte énormément
la voix des autres mais c'est vrai que
tu as 3,1 millions d'abonnés sur un
stats et ndé et des plus grosses
personnalités aujourd'hui sur les
réseaux sociaux
qu'est ce que tu as retenu de ce soir et
que c'est à dire attaque à ceux qui te
suivent m'a déjà c'est on a une grosse
opportunité aujourd'hui d'être présent
ici sur ce plateau est d'être face à un
membre du gouvernement et de lui poser
les questions que tout le monde se pose
et là on a pu lui poser aujourd'hui on a
eu des réponses après voilà le truc du
confinement je pense que si on re
confine je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de
gens qui vont pas tenir le coup donc
c'est un truc qu'il faut éviter à tout
prix et on dit beaucoup les jeunes les
jeunes les jeunes mais voilà nous il
faut quoi si on me donne des vrais
consignes on peut pas nous laisser dans
le flou comme ça et nous dira un jour ci
et l'autre jour ça parce que nous
apprend va être perdus on va pas
comprendre et juste le truc des clusters
que j'ai pas compris avec les
universités au final monsieur le docteur
au final est ce que là les gens qui vont
au lycée est ce qu'ils se transmettent
le virus où il ya vraiment pas de
transmission du virus au lycée au
collège ou dans les universités il ya
des transmissions de virus qui sont
possibles partout la question c'est le
nombre de transmissions qui sont faites
les transmissions elles sont
essentiellement faite par un petit
nombre de personnes qui relancent
l'épidémie dans des circonstances très
particulières sont des circonstances
festives
donc en gros si lés 18 26 ans sont des
fêtes à 15 au lieu de faire des fêtes à
200 ça change tout parce qu'en fait
l'épidémie ne peut pas être lancée
uniquement par des petits kloster
familiaux ou des petits cluster dans des
endroits comme ça ils font vraiment
inquiets des énormes brassage des
énormes fait pour relancer les choses et
si on est vite ça et ben du coup on
arrivera à contrôler cette épidémie on
va tous vivre à peu près normalement on
arrêtera de parler du corona virus tout
le temps parce que salah sera les gens
ont navire reprendra son cours
donc c'est vrai que vous avez une
responsabilité qui est importante on
vous demande pas d'arrêter de faire la
fête pouvait faire la fête à 15 ou 20
on nous demande de ne pas vous rendre
dans les énormes fait il y aura mille
personnes 500 personnes parce que là
vous êtes quasiment sûr de vous
contaminer pas ce qui aura forcément
quelqu'un qui va être contaminés et les
conditions sont telles que vous allez la
trappe et le virus je vous passe les
huit heures à boire à chanter à crier
dans une petite salle avec des gens vous
allez attraper et après vous allez
passer à tout votre entourage qui va
passer à tout l'entourage et vous avez
relancé la machine donc essayer de pas
faire ça et après je vais votre vie
normale chez ministre il faut l'éviter
alors une interview sur gmail etc
s'il accepte devenu tellement trois
choses se soient enfin j'espère vraiment
qu'ils s'y autant la table et ceux qui
nous ont regardés prennent conscience de
la responsabilité et vont essayer
vraiment de faire passer le message que
vient de nous délivrer notre docteur 2
gabriella talent on l'a dit ce soir
j'espère vraiment qu'on va pouvoir
éviter un recond finement ce soir vous
nous avez dit à l'heure qu'il est vous
l'envisagez vous l'envisagez même pas
vous essayer d aller actuelle heures
pour que ça sur la table
voilà c'est pas sur la table 3 et ça
c'est un autre dossier
vraiment je vous le demande à 23h45 en
direct j'espère vraiment qu'on va
pouvoir avancer sur le dossier des
ouigours on voit que sa régie
normalement vraiment vraiment les
réseaux sociaux là dessus j'espère
vraiment que vous allez pouvoir remettre
une petite couche au président est
peut-être aller voir d'autres pays que
l'europe s'allie avec vous et fasse une
alliance est ici est vraiment de faire
un blocus économique pour que la chine
puisse entendre qu' ils ne peuvent pas
se comporter comme ça ça me fait super
plaisir cyril que ce soit nos noms nos
jeunes là sur le plateau qui est soulevé
la problématique mais c'est vrai c'est
après on me parle des jeunes souvent y
croient plus ils ont plein de vie ils
ont ils sont plein de valeurs quoi ils
ont envie d'avoir un monde harmonieux
une france métissée qui se respecte de
que signifie cette jeunesse là il faut
s'appuyer dessus
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien je veux dire de base c'est
pas notre rôle à nous en vérité de
soulever ce genre de problème là et de
les mettre en lumière c'est plus le rôle
des médias principalement et nous ce
qu'on fait ça on le fait parce que en
fait au bout d'un moment on est obligé
si personne ne le fait bah c'est non on
va sortir les données fait si on va le
faire quoi bravo bravo et merci d'avoir
été là juste dernière chose
gabriella talent j'aimerais vraiment que
vous teniez l'engagement que vous avez
pris avec nos influenceurs d'essayer de
faire des réunions toutes les semaines
si vous voulez que je vous aide avec eux
à le faire il ya aucun souci et je pense
que c'est bénéfique pour vous et pour
les influenceurs voilà qui sont là qui
ont été excellentes ce soir je voulais
vous remercier
[Applaudissements]
merci d'avoir été là c'est merci à lui
merci beaucoup à mine merci docteur
martin de la chine qui a été très bon
[Applaudissements]
d'avoir est avec nous jefferies a dit
merci et merci
je veux remercier mes deux soeurs émises
et julien merci merci madame merci bien
sûr au karim zéribi tout de suite c'est
le débrief avec eric naulleau et je
voudrais vous remercier
gabriella talent parce que c'était pas
évident en libye le gouvernement on
voulait juste vraiment que les jeunes
puissent s'exprimer c'est ce que vous
avez fait vous leur avez dit vraiment ce
que vous en pensez ce soir vous à poser
les vraies questions il ya des trucs qui
nous plaisent des trucs qui nous
plaisent moins et on vous l'a dit
maintenant on espère que les choses vont
avancer parce que c'est important et que
vous tiendrez les engagements que vous
avez pris ce soir ouigours influenceurs
et on a dit un troisième producteur
russe de la faillite et russes de la
fête exact merci gabri gendrey mes
engagements
merci à vous merci à vous d'avoir
organisé cette émission parce que ça
n'avait pas été proposée avant de faire
une émission par les jeunes pour les
jeunes pour passer des messages aux
jeunes et c'est une vraie responsabilité
que que vous avez su saisir et donc
merci beaucoup et moi je serai au rendez
vous de mes engagements ma pensez vous
qu'ils devraient être au rendez-vous
quand j'organiserai des réunions au
ministère pour en échange ba ba ils ont
plus de fait mal au ministère l'adepte
intervenants qui vont arriver dans un
instant et qu'eric naulleau qui vont
donner leur avis qui vaut également
poser des questions à nos éditorialistes
merci d'avoir été avec les tonguiens
[Applaudissements]
tous
[Musique]
key pnue de parfums by dolce and gabbana
je peux vous proposer du blanc du blanc
léger qu'à ses brillants poudré ou un
plan sombre où vous n'auriez pas
quelques chose de plus original poignet
le monde avec un oeil nouveau
skoda qu'annick la nouvelle référence
des suv urbain skoda est disponible dès
maintenant à partir de 199 euros par
mois hors prime à la conversion
[Musique]
les nuits sont toujours plus longs quand
on a mal aux dents
même quand elles ont fini de pousser
alors quel que soit votre âge avec
groupama santé active nos d'antibes
partenaire vous soigne avec des
avantages privilégiées groupama la vraie
vie ça sur ici et en ce moment jusqu'à
200 euros offerts pour de nouvelles
souscriptions de contrats santé et
prévoyance
hu à 12h30
nouveau rana frais minutes des pâtes
fraîches et une sauce onctueuse avec des
ingrédients de qualité à cuisiner en
seulement cinq minutes
non mais t'es sérieux là
cherry qu'est ce tu fais au bureau rama
frais minutes et vous quelle bonne
excuse allez vous inventez seller
génialissime chez gifi
découvrez la bouilloire à 15 euros elle
change de couleur en fonction de la
température de l'eau idéal pour les
amateurs de thé et pour mieux
l'apprécier
la bouteille était à 5 euros et le bugue
à 79 centimes retrouvez toutes nos idées
génialissime chez gifi gifi lisicki
génie pour payer dans nos factures
échangées notre chaudière fatigué par
une pompe à chaleur sur le sur les
travaux réussis c'est simple c'est easy
parlons peu parlons encore pourquoi ma
vidéo est excellent pour l'emploi des
jeunes
parce que chaque année partout en france
les équipes de nos restaurants ouvrent
grand leurs portes à des milliers de
nouveaux collaborateurs
avec des cdi à la clé que ce soit pour
un premier job ou pour bien plus
longtemps
nous sommes ainsi le premier recruteur
en france et 80 % de nos employés sont
des jeunes de moins de 30 ans alors oui
chapeau ensemble faisons les choses en
grand
[Musique]
les recettes sont toujours meilleures
quand on les prépare en famille
non
amusez vous en souhaitant la préparation
mélanger avec beaucoup d'amour
et une pincée de souris l'a laissé levé
et enfin décorer avec le délicieuse
touche de gourmandise parce que nutella
ajoute toujours quelque chose d'unique
nutella c'est si bon d'être ensemble
[Musique]
joignez tech
m
nouvelle seat leon découvrez-les
hybrides rechargeables et sans
engagement
[Musique]
bah voyons
le patron tu te réveilles moi je rêve je
cours après et pour les battre ce
cauchemar on est très mal
l'idole trop forts sur les prix et c'est
vous qui le dites depuis dix ans la
rentrée c'est le bon moment pour
redémarrer prendre un nouveau départ
choisir de faire soi même ses smart
choisir de se lancer ses smart choisir
de rénover sa maison
six marques trouvons ensemble les
meilleures solutions pour y arriver chez
sofinco profiter d'un taux à 0,5 pour
cent et parce que vous accompagnez c'est
aussi vous protéger la garantie pouvoir
d'achat vous est offerte aujourd'hui
plus que jamais nous conseillers sont à
votre écoute 30,05 sofinco smartphones
ce matin
[Musique]
ça m'aurait ci feraient s'ils font tant
sa mort est quoi de meilleur que son
goût primer avant vous ne vous aimiez
pas avec votre deuxième père mais ça
c'était avant
pendant les jours crise la deuxième
paire de marque est offert avec ou sans
rendez vous chez crise c'est comme vous
aimez dispositif médical
retrouvez chaque jour le vrai prix de
bonnes choses saisie en août nature au
sucre de canne de 0,10 on le traîne
encore lidl trop forts sur les prix et
c'est vous qui le dites depuis dix ans
[Musique]
place aux nouvelles technologies
place au nouveau design
[Musique]
place à l'inspiration
nouveau suv mini countryman disponible
en édition suréquipés à partir d'autres
près 170 euros par mois sans aucun
apport
[Musique]
votre programme avec la suffit de gaines
point fr gagnent ainsi sentent qu'ils
affinent et sculpter votre silhouette
classifie deviennent point fr votre
programme avec le groupe rodin retraite
prévoyance assurance vie gros pro d'un
penser votre épargne
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans la
terre l'émission qui les confine la
parole nous allons bien sûr revenir sur
ce qui sévit dans ballon ce temps poste
et nous poser la question qui inquiète
que dis-je qui angoisse tous les
français faut-il craindre un confinement
et pour un bon débat il faut des
chroniqueurs avec un bon débit ce qui
est le cas de thierry chèze deux gringos
masai et deux autres releveurs d'olivier
d'arrêt d'auxerre diallo de kaspar
zehnder de raquel garrido de yann moix
et diverses remarquable acier qui a bien
voulu rester avec nous est ce que tout
le monde a fait ses devoirs vous avez
tous regardés balancement pas sûr à des
questions très précises sur ce qui s'est
passé des choses après le récapitulatif
alors qu'il ya encore quelques semaines
l'idée d'un nouveau confinement semblait
complètement imaginaire depuis quelques
jours la menace semble bel et bien réel
leur confinement risque d'arriver à
toute allure
c'est tout le pays qui retient son
souffle en vivent dans la peur de devoir
se reconfigurer façon on va retourner en
consumant pas l'air très rassuré l eau
ne vend pas trop il faut dire que chaque
jour les chiffres de l'épidémie ne cesse
d'augmenter le nombre de nouveaux cas
est à 8000 51 les cas confirmés en 24
heures eh bien on a plus de 12000 845 de
gouvernement de son côté ne semble pas
avoir de vision à long terme ni savoir
quelle méthode adoptée
nous sommes dans une phase d'aggravation
depuis plusieurs semaines de la
circulation du virus mais malgré ces
mauvais indicateurs on se demande si la
france est en mesure financièrement
parlant de remettre tout le pays à
l'arrêt leur confinement sera
catastrophique pour l'économie
alors selon vous faut-il craindre
confinement
alors d'abord il faut vérifier quelque
chose qui parmi vous je vivre un nouveau
confinement qui veut à nouveau vivre
cette expérience
je voulais simplement vérifier ça c'est
clair
alors avant d'aller dans le vif du sujet
d'abord je me tourne vers guernesey
il ya une grande expérience de la
communication à haut niveau et je
voudrais un petit jugement sur
l'exercice auquel s'est livrée gabriela
talent qui était pas facile c'est jamais
facile dans ces cas la drogue
quel regard vous portez sur sa
prestation déjà je pense que c'était une
bonne idée est assez courageux de venir
parce qu'il savait pas trop comment ça
allait se passer mais je pense qu il eu
raison de le faire parce qu'il s'est
confronté à des questions inattendues du
public des chroniqueurs des intervenants
échelons qui s'en est bien sorti calme
pédago moi j'ai été rassurée notamment
par le fait que visiblement la
perspective d'un confinement n'était pas
sur la table ce qui est quand même la
bonne nouvelle de la soirée et je pense
que ça sera utile pour la suite on verra
dans les jours qui viennent s'il a
réussi à convaincre la jeunesse qui
était quand même l'objectif
moi j'ai aussi j'ai eu cette impression
que leur confinement en tout cas au sens
pas sur la table où on l'a connu ne se
sait pas pour demain tout le monde a
cette impression bruno est ce que vous
allez aussi cette impression
oui c'est l'impression que j'ai eue et
puis en même temps je pense que j'ai
entendu sur les missions précédentes on
attend quand même beaucoup taper sur le
gouvernement
et je pense quand même que le
gouvernement a fait quand même beaucoup
de choses à l'occasion de tout ce qui
s'est passé depuis plusieurs mois je
pense entre autres à les deux sur le
chômage partiel c'est près de 7
milliards qui ont été débloqués
je crois que le gouvernement a fait
quand même un geste c'est intéressant